et bien bonsoir à tous et à toutes merci
d'être avec nous pour cette soirée
spéciale pour information nous sommes en
direct en ce moment même sur TV 78 bien
entendu donc voilà c'est magie du direct
comme on dit toujours cette soirée notre
hôte
UGC 50 ans en Yvelines qui nous
accueille merci Marc de nous accueillir
merci d'être notre partenaire depuis
quatre années maintenant pour le
festival TV 78 ce festival de films
documentaire 51 50 événements pour un
festival merci beaucoup parce que cette
initiative elle est due à toi et attirée
barbenette notre directeur de tv78 elle
est née il y a 4 ans avec la volonté
d'unir les différentes salles
culturelles sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin d'unir les différents
moyens de communication qui était et qui
sont à notre disposition la télévision
les cinémas la radio les salles
culturelles de 50 ans en Yvelines et de
venir également l'ensemble des arts et
de montrer que l'art ça peut également
être l'information et que l'armée aussi
à la connaissance bien entendu d'où la
c'est de ce concours parce que ça reste
un concours ce concours de films
documentaire
comme tu le dis c'est un concours donc
je vous invite tous pour ceux qui
veulent à voter vous avez des votes
notamment du public notamment du cinéma
des 3S mais vous vous pouvez voter sur
le site de TV 78 pour élire le
documentaire qui sera élu à la remise
des prix dimanche soir au ciné 7
d'accord voilà et sur le site
50-1.fr pour require vos votes entre
autres le vote du public et d'ailleurs
notre directeur nous a amené un des
trophées qui sera remis donc dimanche au
ciné 7 à Élancourt tu finis à le dire
parce que c'est un peu notre jeu à tous
les deux puisque donc j'ai le plaisir
d'être présent de cette chaîne mais
également d'être le président du cinéma
d'Élancourt et on a un petit peu un jeu
c'est qu'on démonte que les multiplex
savent travailler avec les les cinémas
locaux et je crois qu'il y a pas de
guerre on en a jamais eu entre nous et
je reviens un petit peu sur le le
festival qu'on a monté il y a maintenant
4 ans avec Iris ici on s'est dit au
cours d'un déjeuner qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour essayer de créer un lien au
niveau de l'agglomération et on a eu
cette idée de créer maintenant depuis
quatre ans ce festival donc chaque année
il y a un thème différent cette année
naturellement c'est l'espace et vous
attendez tous dans quelques minutes les
gens qui ont bercé notre enfance
notamment la mienne qui nous ont fait
découvrir l'espace mais je vous rappelle
aussi que c'est encore jusqu'à dimanche
que vous avez plein d'animations
notamment à l'UGC ou tout ce weekend
vous pourrez gratuitement aussi voir
assister à des séances de planétarium un
goûter philosophique pour les enfants
entre 7 et 10 ans donc inscrivez-vous et
dans le centre commercial pour ceux qui
veulent s'initier au pilotage de drone
vous avez dans un magasin qui est las
vide je le répète tous les jours mais
vous avez vous pouvez vous initier au
pilotage de drone dans le centre
commercial et c'est une expérience assez
intéressante à faire donc je vous
encourage
et également un petit mot sur le
festival qui se tient ici mais sur de
nombreux sites du territoire il y a une
exposition qui vient d'être inaugurée à
la bibliothèque universitaire sur
télécommandes vous pouvez également
retrouver tous les soirs à minuit des
films toute la journée des documentaires
vous avez le programme à la fois qui est
à l'accueil du cinéma et sur le site
50-1.fr donc on a ce festival et venez
voter et venez à la soirée de clôture
dimanche au ciné 7 mais maintenant c'est
la soirée
oui parce qu'on m'a dit que le public
n'est pas venu pour nous voir je suis un
petit peu déçu c'est on pensait qu'on
allait faire une heure et demie de
discours mais je pense que ça va pas
être le cas
tu l'as un petit peu 10 marques et ils
ont bercé notre jeunesse mais il n'était
pas seul il y avait également des
journalistes des journées ce
scientifiques des journalistes de renom
et en particulier qui est là ce soir qui
va nous faire l'honneur de cette
présentation alors j'ai une petite fiche
parce que il a fait tellement de choses
que sans souvenir même si alors j'ai une
anecdote personnelle mais Jean-Claude ne
s'en souvient pas c'est pas grave il est
animé il y a une époque une émission il
recevait des jeunes lauréats de pays
scientifiques entre autres un prix qui
s'appelle prix scientifique Philips et à
l'époque j'étais passionné de
météorologie et il m'avait interviewé
mais il l'a oublié et donc ça me fait
partie en plaisir ce soir de pouvoir le
vous le présenter donc il a été
rédacteur en chef et présentateur des
journaux télévisés de TF1 depuis 1975 en
1987 il a été rédacteur en chef le
présentateur des journaux de 13h sur la
5 pour ceux qui se souviennent de la
Saint qui comprit ce moment
terrible de la de la fin des émissions
et de l'écran noir moi je me souviens
que ça m'avait beaucoup marqué de 94 à
99 il a été rédacteurs en chef de Radio
Monte Carlo il a été créateur du presque
Club de France à ma connaissance il est
d'ailleurs toujours membre du conseil
d'administration mais on le connaît
aussi pour bien entendu sa passion des
sciences et puis ça comment dirais-je je
sais pas si ma passion suffit en tout
cas oui une passion absolument exacerbée
sur sur ce qui s'est appelé et ce qui
s'appelle toujours en français les ovnis
les objets volant d'une identifié en
effet à l'automne 1973 Jean-Claude est
intrigué par l'information qui est
diffusée par une dépêche de l'AFP il
s'agit de l'observation d'un ovni
au-dessus de l'aéroport de Turin pour
ceux qui s'en souviennent
en 74 la rubrique d'ossieu OVNI dans
l'émission de Claude Villers
il y participe il a créé il réalise un
scoop extraordinaire avec l'interview du
ministre de la Défense de l'époque pour
ceux qui se souviennent et qui sont
vieux que moi c'était Robert Gallet qui
admet que l'armée française donc le
ministre de la Défense et confronté très
souvent à des phénomènes de type OVNI ce
qui durait c'est accélérera la création
du GEPAN le groupe d'études des
phénomènes aérospatio non identifiés qui
dépend toujours aujourd'hui du CNES
il a collaboré avec les frères Bogdanov
mais nous en dira plus dans quelques
instants en 2009 sur France 2 entre
autres pour le 40e anniversaire des
premiers pas de l'homme sur la lune et
des tueurs des fusées Apollo de 69 à 70
et souvenons-nous aussi de ce moment
Jean-Claude Bourret a été un envoyé
spécial à Houston de France Inter et il
a obtenu d'ailleurs en exclusivement
éviter mondiale il y a l'origine les
vrais motifs de l'explosion d'Apollo 13
il est bien entendu l'auteur de OVNI
l'extraordinaire découverte donc il a
écrit avec en collaboration avec
Jean-Pierre Petit en 2017 je vous
demande donc d'accueillir tous vos
applaudissements
Jean-Claude Bourret
[Applaudissements]
et bien mesdames messieurs c'est un
grand plaisir un grand honneur d'être
devant vous ce soir puisque vous allez
avoir la joie d'abord de faire la
connaissance mais vous les connaissez
déjà mais là ce sera InVivo des célèbres
frères Bogdanov docteur en physique
docteur en mathématiques des grosses
têtes comme on dit en matière de science
et vous verrez le film documentaire
qu'ils ont réalisé sur l'exobiologie
alors l'exobiologie moi je vis avec
depuis plus de 40 ans près d'un
demi-siècle
l'exobiologie c'est la science
potentielle de forme de vie existant
dans l'univers et j'ai la chance d'avoir
vécu toutes l'évolution
de la mentalité scientifique de la
mentalité du grand public on appelle 40
ans car quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser aux objets volants dans
l'identifié évidemment dès qu'on parlait
des ovnis et des soucoupes volantes il y
avait un petit sourire en coin en disant
tout ça c'est des bêtises ça n'existe
pas
et puis en 1995 on a découvert la
première exoplanète c'est d'ailleurs
depuis l'observatoire les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence qu'on l'a fait
en France
maintenant on en est à plus de 4000 mais
surtout ce que peu de gens savent y
compris peut-être parmi vous qui êtes là
ce soir et qui est donc particulièrement
affûté dans le domaine de l'exobiologie
la déclaration de la NASA est un peu
plus trois ans qui a dit ceci nous avons
étudié les derniers clichés envoyés par
nos satellites les plus performants
Apple planque etc et nous estimons
écoutez bien le nombre à 60 milliards le
nombre de planètes pouvant abriter la
vie dans notre seule galaxie 60
milliards dans notre seule galaxie et la
NASA ajouté dans ce communiqué nous
estimons désormais en ayant recompté les
étoiles grâce à nos observatoires les
plus puissants qui tournent désormais
autour de la Terre nous estimons qu'il
n'y a pas entre 100 et 200 milliards de
galaxies comme on l'a dit et écrit
depuis presque un siècle mais qu'il y a
plus de 2000 milliards de galaxies et on
en découvre pratiquement une tous les 15
jours ce qui veut dire que dans notre
environnement
le nombre de galaxies le nombre de
planètes pouvant abriter la vie est
tellement immense qu'imaginait que nous
sommes les seuls êtres intelligents
j'ose à peine
ajouté intelligent à être parce que si
on est les êtres les plus intelligents
du cosmos et du souci à se faire avec
les guerres les famines les gilets
jaunes en ce moment qui montrent qu'il y
a quand même plein d'êtres humains qui
qui crèvent la dalle et qui ont même pas
de quoi à joindre les deux bouts donc il
y a pas de quoi rouler les mécaniques
c'est pas parce qu'on a des smartphones
des ordinateurs une télévision en
couleur il faut pas oublier qu'on est 7
milliards et demi bientôt humiliaires
sur la planète Terre et que à peu près
la moitié de la population mondiale vit
avec moins de trois dollars par jour
donc vous voyez qu'on a encore beaucoup
de progrès à faire on est violent il y a
sans arrêt des problèmes
d'assassinats des problèmes de viol etc
c'est ça la plus grande civilisation du
cosmos ça me fait toujours rire quand je
discute avec des scientifiques qui
tellement peur d'être descendu de leur
piédestal parce qu'ils sont agrégés de
ceci ou de cela qui sont directeurs de
recherche et qui sont au sommet de la
pyramide intellectuelle qu'il se disent
bon sang mais si un extraterrestre qui
vient je vais être quoi moi par rapport
à lui et ben tu vas être comme de tous
rien du tout une formule par rapport à
un prix Nobel et encore alors
[Musique]
justement encore avant d'accueillir les
frères Bogdanov je connais votre
impatience nous sommes donc sur une
petite boule qui se refroidit qui
s'appelle la terre qui tourne à 106.000
km/h autour du Soleil en 365 jours le
soleil est sur le bord de la galaxie qui
tourne sur le elle-même en quelques
dizaines de millions d'années même plus
de 100 millions d'années et là nous
sommes à plus de 800 000 km/h mais la
galaxie elle s'éloigne du point
d'explosion original qu'on appelle le
Big Bang et là nous sommes à 2 millions
400 000 km/h c'est à dire qu'à chaque
seconde nous parcourons là en ce moment
presque 700 km
par seconde Paris - Marseille à chaque
seconde alors que vous êtes
tranquillement assis tout ceci pour vous
dire méfiez-vous de l'apparence de la
logique les frères Bogdanov
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
bonsoir
et merci merci Jean-Claude de cette
présentation magnifique dans notre
voyage dans la galaxie merci à vous
d'être ce soir avec nous pour partager
ces grandes questions vous savez que
Igor et moi depuis que nous avons créé
dans X donc le 21 avril 1979 nous nous
efforçons de répondre de manière simple
à des questions parfois compliquées
c'est vrai
mais parmi ces questions que vous vous
posez peut-être ou que vous ne vous
posez pas il y en a une qui est très
importante et je voudrais la partager
avec vous juste en signe de prologue
dans notre rencontre ce soir c'est une
question qui a été soulevée par
quelqu'un que Igor a rencontré il y a
quelques mois
au célèbre marché aux puces
et qui est assez étonnante vous allez
voir mais oui parce que la question à
laquelle nous pensons que Sky et moi et
que nous voulons partager avec vous si
celle-ci qui est Igor
c'est vrai que c'est une question
à laquelle à laquelle nous pouvons
répondre jusqu'à et moi enfin pas
toujours mais pratiquement toujours mais
à laquelle beaucoup de gens ne répondent
pas un jour je suis donc il y a à peu
près un an je suis au marché aux puces
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
connaissent cette histoire parce que je
l'ai raconté à de multiples reprises
tellement les savoureuses tu la connais
pas Jean-Claude je suis donc au marché
aux puces dans les tapisserie tapisserie
ancienne et tout à coup je vois
quelqu'un qui qui font la foule il y a
beaucoup de monde les allées des pouces
sont étroites il avance vers moi je vois
qu'il est
tunisien marocain en tout cas il vient
de cette belle région du monde
il pointe un doigt dans ma direction il
a un sourire bienveillant sur le visage
et il me pose cette question étonnante
il me dit vous allez voir dites
si votre frère
est-ce que vous mesurez la densité
métaphysique de la question
question inouï inouï c'est vous c'est
votre frère alors moi j'ai pas pu
résister à cette réponse je dis enfin
vous voyez bien que c'est pas moi
et c'est mon frère voyons et là il a eu
cette cette réponse ultime encore plus
intelligente que la mienne puisqu'il me
dit ah mais
[Rires]
ça c'est le charme de la gemmalité mais
il y a une histoire qui encore dans la
même veine qui est aussi extraordinaire
sur les frères jumeaux on a eu la chance
de rencontrer un jour chez un ami le
grand Coluche Coluche qu'on connaissait
pas qu'on n'avait jamais rencontré mais
qui nous connaissait probablement par la
télévision et se plante comme ça vers
nous il vient vers nous il regarde
alternativement et puis il dit cette
chose qui est assez extraordinaire vous
allez voir l'esprit de finesse de
Coluche il nous dit mais ça alors
j'aurais très bien qui est je reconnais
Grichka il y a aucun problème je sais
qui c'est
happy whisky je reconnais très bien Igor
aucun doute je me trompe pas
mais bon sang mais en plus je vous
regarde
plus je sais pas du tout et jamais je
pourrais reconnaître lequel des deux est
les frères Bogdanoff
voilà le grand Coluche notre splendeur
vous voyez est-ce que est-ce qu'on a
répondu à la question de savoir qui est
bon on fait un vote
pour savoir un petit peu celui qui est à
ma gauche
oui non
oui oui quand même il y a des oui il y a
des oui quand même
on lève la main comme ça on voit clair
et celui et celui qui est donc
celui qui est donc à la droite ici donc
oui
et on lève la main oui ben oui oui voilà
tous les autres forcément
et bien non
[Musique]
et non voilà Igor est ici Grichka est là
c'est moi et nous sommes tellement
heureux d'être avec vous que on pourrait
presque se prendre l'un pour l'autre
mais on est vraiment ravis d'être là ce
soir
avec quoi qu'il en soit nous allons
partager ce soir avec vous une question
qui est vraiment essentielle et à
laquelle l'humanité n'a pas trouvé de
réponse jusqu'à ce jour qui est celle de
savoir si oui ou non il y a d'autres
formes de vie ailleurs ailleurs que sur
la terre Fontenelle vous savez qui est
mort à sang plus de 100 ans
en son temps à écrire un livre qui
s'intitulait qui s'intitule toujours
d'ailleurs de la pluralité des mondes
habités il y croyait
bien de bien bien son nombreux sont à
l'époque des esprits qui sont convaincus
que ce qui s'est passé sur la terre
c'est à dire l'apparition de la vie
n'est pas un phénomène isolé à notre
planète et que
et que la vie s'est développée ailleurs
mais aucune preuve
et oui on recherche des preuves
on les a presque trouvé on pensait les
avoir trouvé au 19e siècle le grand
Camille Flammarion une école vivante
dans le domaine de la science quelqu'un
qui incarnait le savoir astronomique au
sommet le grand Camille Flammarion avait
cru déceler sur la planète rouge vous
savez la planète Mars qui gravite entre
150 millions et parfois 200 millions de
kilomètres selon la distance orbitale le
grand Camille Flammarion
accru découvrir des canaux sur Mars avec
chaparelli avec d'autres des
scientifiques de l'époque les canaux
étaient là signature d'une civilisation
ils se sont dit mais oui les martiens
ils existent ils sont là et quelques
années plus tard en 1895 voilà que un
grand romancier prend la relève et donne
à cette mythologie martienne une vraie
consistance oui les martiens ils sont là
et c'est ainsi que va débarquer sur
terre des envahisseurs qui viennent de
là-bas et c'est la fameuse guerre des
mondes vous avez certainement entendu
parler de ce livre publié par berbère
George Wells écrivain anglais
anglo-américain d'ailleurs
extraordinairement puissant et fertile
qui a donc engendré cette extraordinaire
roman La Guerre des mondes c'est pour
vous dire que
cette angoisse de voir d'autres
êtres vivants à cette époque-là sur
d'autres mondes et très très puissante
était vraiment puissante
et elle s'est propagée tout au long du
20e siècle pour autant comme le vient le
dirigore
on n'a aucune preuve jusqu'à présent ils
peuvent exister alors on s'interroge
Jean-Claude magnifiquement avec beaucoup
de brio
nous a donné quelques éclairages en
disant effectivement que
dans notre seule galaxie il y a 300
milliards de soleil alors imaginez que
un seul soleil sur 1000
contiennent la vie un seul soleil sur
1000 ça fait pas beaucoup un seul soleil
sur 1000 pourrait abriter une planète
qui elle-même contient la vie
mais ça fait quand même encore 300
millions
300 millions de systèmes solaires
comparables au nôtres c'est encore que
le chiffre est extraordinairement
conservateur parce que vous avez entendu
ce cas ce qu'a dit Jean-Claude tout à
l'heure relayant une information qui a
été transmise par la NASA il y a 3 ans
disant que on peut
raisonnablement penser qu'il existe au
moins 60 milliards de planètes
susceptibles d'habiter la vie mais alors
juste une petite pause parce que on
parle de milliards ce sont des chiffres
qui sont un peu abstraits on ne se rend
pas compte de ce que c'est savez-vous je
vous pose cette question mes amis
savez-vous combien de temps nous
devrions rester dans cette salle
ensemble pour arriver à compter sur nos
doigts au rythme d'un chiffre par
seconde 1 2 3 jusqu'à 1 milliard à votre
avis
combien de temps combien de temps
faut-il pour compter jusqu'à 1 milliard
six mois
un an 80 ans
mais oui bravo vous voyez que 50 ans on
se dit bien c'est pas simplement je
crois que dans je veux le slogan de
Saint-Quentin
qui est la ville de l'innovation mais
c'est aussi la ville de la science parce
que bravo vous êtes c'est la première
fois qu'on me répond la plupart du temps
on me dit oh il faudrait peut-être aller
12 heures ou un jour deux jours mais non
pas du tout il faut en effet 80 ans 80
ans pour compter jusqu'à 1 milliard
alors si on devait dire 80 ans pour un
milliard regardez il faut multiplier ce
nombre par 60
vous voyez ce que ça fait ce sont des
siècles et des siècles et des siècles
donc
la probabilité pour que la vie existe
ailleurs est incommensurablement grande
parce que comme le disait Jean-Claude
jusqu'à présent on pensait qu'il y avait
100 milliards de galaxies tout au plus
mais non il y en a beaucoup plus
on pensait il y a encore trois ans que
il y avait 1000 milliards de galaxies et
bien aujourd'hui on sait qu'il y a pas
1000 milliards de galaxies mais
vraisemblablement le double 2000
milliards de galaxies et on continue
d'en découvrir chaque jour
donc 60 milliards multipliés par ne
serait-ce que 1000 milliards vous voyez
c'est un vertige de chiffres qui nous
environne qui nous emportent qui nous
entraînent et qui nous amène à penser
que oui c'est vrai la probabilité pour
que nous soyons avec des cousins qui
nous ressemblent peut-être ou pas dans
l'univers est immense c'est ce que vous
allez découvrir maintenant à travers un
document que nous avons eu le plaisir
jusqu'à et moi de de produire et de
présenter
c'était sur France 2 il y a c'était en
2011 donc il y a pas très longtemps et à
partir de là vous allez voir dans ce
film que la communauté scientifique
comme on dit aujourd'hui aujourd'hui et
bien se laisse aller à penser
quelquefois avec réticence souvent avec
peu plaisir on fait en tout cas les
scientifiques que vous allez découvrir
dans ce film en sont convaincus cela a
pensé donc que en effet la vie est un
phénomène universel qu'elle s'est
développée ailleurs et que dans les
quelques années qui viennent nous allons
en recueillir les preuves matérielles
par l'observation voilà donc bon film et
à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'année 2040 amis distance de la Terre
et du soleil voici un télescope d'un
genre entièrement nouveau composé de
milliers de miroirs dispersés dans
l'espace qui recombine leurs images dans
un satellite collecteur son but observer
la surface de planète lointaine
et voici la surprise l'image d'un monde
étranger à des centaines de milliards de
kilomètres de la Terre
regardez ces tâches bleues et vertes se
sont probablement des océans et des
continents et ces lignes lumineuses
peut-être des
monde de glace monde de feu planète
géante bientôt une nouvelle terre
comment apparaît la vie est-elle un
phénomène rare ou très fréquent dans
l'univers
des milliards de soleil des milliards de
planètes dans notre seule galaxie
combien abrite des civilisations
intelligentes si la vie intelligente
existe dans l'univers pourrions-nous
communiquer avec elle et qu'aurions-nous
à nous dire
[Musique]
s'ils existent pourquoi garde-t-il le
silence
qui nous étions seuls absolument seul
dans l'univers
bienvenue à tous chaque fois que par une
belle nuit sans nuage vous levez les
yeux vers les milliers d'étoiles qui
brillent dans le ciel vous vous posez
cette question presque inévitablement
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres mondes là-haut
plus ou moins semblables au nôtres
d'autres planètes qui ressembleraient à
la terre en 1995 on a découvert la
première planète située hors de notre
système solaire une planète beaucoup
plus grosse que la Terre un monde géant
un monde de gaz qui ressemble à Jupiter
à partir de là
tout est allé très vite désormais on a
découvert plus de 400 planètes la
plupart sont des géants gazeuses mais
pas miel on a fini par découvrir des
petits monde solides dont la taille est
comparable à celle de la Terre et c'est
là la vraie révolution mais oui
rappelez-vous le 4 avril 2007 une équipe
d'astronomes français portugais et
suisse annonce que pour la première fois
on a trouvé une planète presque
semblable à la Terre autour d'une étoile
située à environ 20 années-lumière de
Chine une découverte fantastique dans
quelques années à peine
nous allons enfin avoir la preuve que la
vie a pu se développer ailleurs que sur
la terre pas seulement une vie
microscopique bloquée au stade de la
bactérie non des organismes complexes
évolués conscient et peut-être même
intelligent et qui sait peut-être que
certains d'entre eux ont réussi à
rabatir des civilisations plus ou moins
semblables à la nôtre alors
embarquons-nous vers ces fantastique
planètes partout à la recherche de ces
nouveaux mondes grâce auxquels nous
allons enfin découvrir que nous ne
sommes peut-être pas seuls dans
l'univers
des planètes par centaines bientôt par
milliers nous le savons à présent
l'univers en regorge et peut-être sur
quelques-unes de ces planètes la vie et
pourquoi pas l'intelligence c'est le
nouveau rêve des astronomes one 1 5 0 0
0 0 avec encore plein de zéro 24 0 en
tout c'est le nombre de planètes
semblables à la Terre un nombre énorme
de terre dans notre univers
que notre planète soit la seule planète
possédant une vie intelligente dans
l'univers il se serait ça le miracle
mais find nous avons estimé qu'il y
avait 31 513 civilisations intelligentes
dans une galaxie d'un milliard d'étoiles
personnellement je suis prêt à parier
pour nos anciens que on va découvrir la
vie ailleurs dans l'univers
c'est passionnante qui a des nouveaux
mondes a commencé depuis un demi-siècle
par l'exploration de notre système
solaire
fascinant pour les astronomes les
résultats ont déçus ce qui attendait la
vie
mais cette exploration n'est pas
terminée loin de là et de nouveaux
espoirs se profilent avec l'émission
futures faire des planètes géantes
Saturne et Jupiter
2029 ce sera le grand retour sur Titan
le plus gros satellite de Saturne
rappelez-vous c'était le 14 janvier 2005
la petite sandwig gaz nous avait révélé
cet étonnant paysage de montagnes et de
vallées comparable à un bord de mer au
sol sous le ciel orangé en pouvait voir
des galets de glace d'eau c'était un
autre monde si proche et pourtant si
loin d'une autre
24 ans après en 2030 une nouvelle
mission automatique libère dans le
crépuscule de titan deux nouveaux enjeux
une montgolfière de 600 kg et une petite
sauce
[Musique]
Athéna costennis co-responsable de cette
collaboration Europe États-Unis nous
comptent ce fantastique voyage comme si
déjà elle y était
dans ce crépuscule le ballon va se
déplacer à 10 km d'altitude et là vous
avez moins 200 degrés Celsius il fait
très très froid donc forcément les
caméras et tous les instruments qu'on a
à bord les caméras les analyseurs tout
ça vont prendre des images du sol mais
on va utiliser aussi un petit peu
quelques flashs pour pouvoir voir un
petit peu ce qui est tout en bas et tout
ce qui nous entoure quand on va passer à
travers l'atmosphère on va quelque part
aussi avaler les aérosols on va regarder
comment elle est faite cette surface de
quoi est faite cette chimie organique
qui va nous permettre de comprendre un
petit peu mieux le degré de complexité
de la chimie organique c'est la atteint
le degré qu'on a sur terre quand on a
besoin de fabriquer des macromolécules
et donner naissance à la vie et dans le
même temps donc ce ballon se déplace
dans un monde extrêmement froid et
extrêmement sombre
lâcher sur un des lacs d'hydrocarbures
de titan la petite sonde cherchera les
traces d'une chimie élémentaire qui
trahirait la présence de la vie
l'inverse se pose on a des instruments
qui sont en dessous qui sont en train de
d'aspirer le liquide qui se trouve dans
ce lac on est en train de le goûter et
avec tous les instruments qu'on a à bord
on va pouvoir faire des analyses
poussées qui vont nous dire d'une part
de quoi est faite cette atmosphère et
d'autre part c'est intérieur est-ce
qu'il y a vraiment de l'eau liquide
c'est ce qui nous intéresse et pour
avoir de l'eau liquide à l'intérieur de
titan que vous avez besoin d'ammoniac
elle a cette atterrisseur est en train
de nous montrer que oui il y a des
traces d'ammoniaques dans dans ces
liquides dans ce lac et on se dit mais
il y a un océan à l'intérieur de titan à
l'océan d'eau qui peut être abrite la
vie si c'est pas aujourd'hui ça sera un
jour
la vie on espère aussi la trouver sur en
cela un autre satellite de Saturne
regardez à l'horizon de gigantesques
geyser de glace d'eau jaillissent à la
surface alimenté par un océan intérieur
l'occasion est trop belle nous irons
aussi sur un seul âne notre mission
notre orbiteur s'approche et plonge à
l'intérieur de ces geysers à l'intérieur
de ses plumes et ramasse tout le
matériel que nous allons par la suite
analyser sur terre
compte tenu de la température très basse
la vie qu'on trouvera peut-être sur un
cela nous dit temps ne sera jamais
qu'une vie très élémentaire plutôt les
précurseurs de la vie que la vie
elle-même
pour trouver des formes de vie plus
complexes les espoirs se tournent à
présent vers les exoplanètes
c'est-à-dire des planètes qui orbitent
autour d'autres soleils que le mot
aujourd'hui un nouveau satellite porte
les promesses de la découverte de ces
mondes lointains et il s'appelle Corot
[Musique]
nous sommes à Toulouse dans l'enceinte
du Centre national d'études spatiales
voici l'équipe en charge de coraux
et depuis 3 ans le bilan du satellite
chasseurs de planètes ne cesse de
s'enrichir la petite dernière c'est elle
c'est coraux de 9b c'est une planète qui
tourne lentement autour de son étoile
donc cette planète est gazeuse mais elle
est suffisamment loin de son étoile pour
avoir une température assez modérée
tempérée nous disons de l'ordre de la
température qui existe actuellement sur
la terre
malheureusement les gazeuses donc il n'y
a probablement pas de vie sur cette
planète
comment procédons pour trouver aussi
petits objets un dossier grand distance
il ne suffit pas seulement d’accroître
la puissance des télescopes
voici un petit montage qui illustre la
rotation d'une planète autour de son
étoile lorsque cette planète va passer
devant l'étoile il va y avoir une légère
baisse du signal de la lumière qui est
émise par l'étoile la sensibilité de
coraux est-elle qu'il peut déceler de
minuscules baisse de la lumière émise
par les étoiles et donc avoir les signes
possibles qu'il y a des planètes qui
tournent autour de ces étoiles il y a un
deuxième principe qui est donc mis en
oeuvre l'étoile va elle-même être
légèrement attiré par la planète et va
aussi avoir un petit mouvement
d'oscillation et ce mouvement va être
détecté par des instruments au sol sur
des grands télescopes et cette seconde
méthode complémentaire est utilisée pour
valider
l'existence de plan autour d'autres
étoiles
fatalement au début on a commencé par
détecter des planètes géantes et
gazeuses donc un propre à la vie
[Musique]
mais avec les années les mailles du
filet se resserre les astronomes
découvrent aujourd'hui des planètes plus
petites et à surface rocheuse comme la
terre
pour atteindre le but final la
découverte d'une planète semblable à la
Terre il faudra attendre l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle génération de télescope les
hyper télescopes
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'un hyper télescope
c'est un ensemble de petits télescopes
individuels réparties sur une surface
qui stimule en fait le comportement d'un
grand télescope unique et chacun de ces
petits télescopes individuels renvoient
à la lumière vers un télescope qui
recombine la lumière de tous ces petits
télescopes
concrètement si vous voulez observer une
planète entière il vous faut 20 000
mètres carrés de miroir
pour observer ses continents il vous
faut 80 mm carré de miroir et pour
découvrir des traces possibles de vie il
faut 500 mille mètres carrés de miroir
et si maintenant on cherche à voir par
exemple une image de la baie de
Saint-Malo depuis une étoile proche à ce
moment-là avoir des détails de l'ordre
de 500 mètres il faudra considérer un
instrument dont les télescopes seront
répartis sur des bases de 300 000 km la
distance entre la Terre et la Lune et
pour une surface équivalente d'environ 5
millions de mètres carrés c'est à dire à
peu près 1000 fois la surface d'un
terrain de football
[Musique]
mardi 6 avril 2010 académie des sciences
de Paris
ce jour là l'astronome Suisse Michel
Mayor faisait une communication devant
ses pères sur la recherche dans
l'univers de Planète semblables à la
Terre et bien on voit ses anneaux cette
structure qui nous renseigne sur
l'existence des systèmes planètes
en 1995 Michel Mayor fut le tout premier
astronome à jeter son filet sur la
première exoplanète à 40 années-lumière
de la Terre
la voici 51 Pégase une géante gazeuse
comme notre Jupiter
mais la surprise c'était qu'elle gravité
tout près de son étoile Michel Mayor un
tremble encore c'est complètement
anormal une planète de la masse de
Jupiter qui tourne tout près tout près
de son étoile en 4 jours les scénarios
de formation des grandes planètes ne
permettait pas de comprendre un tel
objet et on a dû revoir la théorie d'une
manière fondamentale pour expliquer
comment cette planète qui est
obligatoirement à une grande distance et
bien elle a évolué ou se rapprochant de
l'étoile actuellement maintenant toute
la théorie de la formation des sixième
planétaire doit inclure ce phénomène une
surprise dès la première trouvaille et
la suite sera à la hauteur plus de 400
planètes ont été découvertes en 15 ans
toutes plus surprenante les unes que les
autres
les mots majorité des planètes qui ont
été découvertes un jour sont nos proches
voisines c'est des planètes qui se
trouvent à quelques dizaines et
brutalement sont années lumière cela des
distances considérables mais il y a une
expérience qui a été faite pour chercher
des planètes très très loin en gros on a
regardé pendant des mois en prenant des
photos successives très dose des régions
centrales de la galaxie c'est
l'expérience
ogre au GLA
[Musique]
approchons-nous de cette petite planète
qui a priori n'a rien d'extraordinaire
orgue 05 390
nous glissons à la surface de son sol
gelé mais nous allons avoir une surprise
prends-moi une planète aussi plutôt
glacée elle est très loin de son étoile
très froide comme ça mais au plus elle
est malheureusement pour y a pas de vie
sur une telle planète mais par contre il
doit y avoir un ciel absolument super
pourquoi pas de la galaxie la densité
d'étoiles est beaucoup plus grande un
million de fois avoir plus plus grande
que dans notre voisinage donc imaginons
le ciel que l'on doit avoir depuis
delplanet une myriad des poils 100 fois
1000 fois plus d'eau sur le ciel que ce
qu'on a sur terre malheureusement on
pourra pas y aller
alors bien sûr ce que cherche les
astronomes c'est une nouvelle terre mais
où donc la trouver on aimerait une
petite planète un peu comme la terre et
qui soit justement à la bonne distance
pour qu'il fasse ni trop chaud ni trop
froid église
580d est la première petite planète qui
se trouve dans cette situation c'est pas
vraiment encore du tout une planète
comme la terre elle fait 7 fois la masse
la terre un petit peu trop lourd comme
ça mais elle est dans la zone habitable
de son étoile
Michel Mayer émet aujourd'hui une
hypothèse très personnelle surgissent
581d
[Musique]
une planète
océan
pour Michel Mayor ce serait à l'origine
une planète glacée qui aurait migré et
fondu tout près de son étoile et le
résultat c'est un immense
océan rien à voir avec le ciel
extrêmement fin que l'on connaît sur
terre mais réellement un océan peut-être
de 100 km de profondeur
à présent voici un objet incroyable PSR
1257+12 qui a une fantastique histoire
[Musique]
cette petite planète qui orbite autour
d'un pulsain un cadavre d'étoiles qui
tourbillonne en émettant un jet très
intense de rayons X et ultraviolet
elle fut détectée par hasard en 1990 par
l'instronome polonais 5 ans avant la
découverte officielle de Michel Mayor
mais à cette époque les astronomes
n'étaient pas certains qui pouvaient
s'agir d'une véritable planète mais en
avait tort c'était la première
exoplanète jamais découverte
l'équipe de coraux elle vient de trouver
la plus petite planète connue à ce jour
Coro 7b à peine plus grosse que la Terre
elle tourne en moins de 24 heures autour
de son étoile c'est à dire que pour
cette B et si elle avait des habitants
l'année durait moins d'un jour ça
ressemble à l'histoire du Petit Prince
alors du coup puisqu'elle tourne en
moins d'un jour elle est très très
proche de son étoile elle est très
proche du feu donc il y fait très très
chaud mais comme elle regarde toujours
le même côté l'étoile comme la lune
regarde toujours le même côté de la
terre et bien d'un côté elle est très
chaude et de l'autre elle est
probablement très froide donc si on doit
passer d'un côté à l'autre il faut
passer de son maillot de bain à sa
combinaison de ski
en 15 ans l'univers a radicalement
changé de visage car il regorge de plein
air
vous en convaincre nous sommes allés sur
le campus de l'université de Berkeley où
nous avons rencontré le plus célèbre
astronome américain Jeffrey mars
avec Michel Mayor il fut l'un des
pionniers de la découverte des
exoplanètes
et devant nous à la cafétéria il s'est
livré un petit calcul alors suivez très
attentivement cela en vaut la paix ce
week-end nous pouvons évaluer le nombre
de planètes semblables à la Terre dans
l'univers entier c'est très simple à
calculer nous savons qu'il y a 200
milliards d'étoiles dans notre galaxie
et 15% environ de ces étoiles font des
planètes
alors calculons
cela fait 30 milliards de planètes dans
notre galaxie
et maintenant voyons combien d'entre
elles ressemblent à la terre
probablement 50% de ces planètes
50% de 30 milliards cela donne 15
milliards de planètes semblables à notre
terre
galaxie si nous calculons maintenant
combien cela fait pour l'univers tout
entier cela donne quelque chose comme
100 milliards de galaxies multiplié par
15 milliards de terre ens of you Mount
pour total
500 et plein plein de zéro 24 0
un nombre phénoménal de planètes
habitables dans notre univers
[Musique]
on dépasse ici le domaine de
l'astronomie nous sommes en train
[Musique]
de vie philosophique
la conscience que l'homme a de sa place
dans l'univers
[Musique]
à présent prenons le temps de contempler
notre terre
[Musique]
des jungles épaisses des chutes d'eau
des lacs des océans
[Musique]
ces paysages ne semblent pas fréquents
dans l'univers
la plupart du monde lointains détecté
par les astronomes sont sans doute des
déserts gelés ou brûlants donc stérile
[Musique]
elle regorge de vie
voilà savane dans les forêts au fond des
gouffres océaniques dans des grandes
profondes et dans ces mégalopoles si on
n'est pas des millions d'êtres
intelligents ou supposés tels
comment expliquer cette exception
personnellement je vis très à l'aise
avec l'idée que la vie est un
sous-produit naturel de l'évolution de
l'Univers quand les conditions sont
réunies et bien la vie doit se
développer ça veut pas dire que c'est
l'homme ça veut pas dire c'est une vie
identique à l'autre le plus probable
c'est aussi des des unicellulaires c'est
probablement la plus généraleisée qui
peut exister personnellement je suis
prêt à parier pour dans un siècle que on
va découvrir la vie ailleurs dans
l'univers
sachez-le l'optimisme de Michel Mayer
n'est pas qu'une conviction il est
confirmé par des recherches très
concrètes menées dans les laboratoires
du monde entier
nous sommes ici dans des locaux liés à
la société française d'exobiologie
pas des amateurs de science-fiction mais
des biologistes des chimistes des
astrophysiciens qui travaillent
expérimentalement sur les formes que la
vie pourrait revêtir sur d'autres
planètes que la terre
dans ce laboratoire les exobiologistes
ont reconstitué l'atmosphère de Titan la
grosse lune de Saturne
le mélange dans l'éprouvette que voici
est composé d'azote de méthane et de
monoxyde de carbone
il est plongé dans de l'azote liquide à
- 170 degrés la température qui règne
sur Titan
enfin on fait circuler entre deux
électrodes un courant électrique qui
simule le rayonnement ultraviolet du
soleil
on laisse reposer quelques jours
et voyez le résultat
c'est composé noirâtres qui combine du
carbone et de l'hydrogène
ce sont des composés organiques les
briques à la base de la vie
en 1953 un jeune biologiste américain
stand des Miller avait réussi une
expérience semblable en reconstituant ce
qu'il croyait être l'atmosphère de la
Terre primitive
métal ammoniac hydrogène vapeur d'eau et
lui aussi avait obtenu des composés
organiques pour le grand public ce
résultat sonna comme un coup de tonnerre
le grand public se rendait pas compte
que c'était aussi facile d'obtenir des
composés d'intérêt biologiques dans des
conditions expérimentales assez simples
finalement et cette facilité a été une
énorme surprise une lampe surprise parmi
le grand public et puis une énorme
surprise parmi un certain scientifiques
qui ne pensaient pas qu'en une durée
aussi brève on pouvait fabriquer des
éléments constitutifs de la vie
mais n'allons pas trop vite c'est une
chose d'avoir les briques encore faut-il
construire la maison
plus d'un demi-siècle nous savons que
les plans de l'édifice sont consignés
dans cette longue molécule qu'on appelle
l'ADN l'acide
désoxyribonucléique on ne la trouve pas
hélas au fond des éprouvettes dans les
états de milliard bien évidemment on ne
fabrique pas de bactéries de
micro-organismes on ne fabrique pas non
plus l'acide nucléique ni même de
protéines
euh lorsque l'on fabrique ce sont les
briques de ces molécules géantes l'acide
aminés sont les éléments constitutifs
les briques des protéines on fabrique
aussi des petits morceaux des acides
nucléiques mais uniquement des petits
morceaux des toutes petites briques
maintenant pour passer de ces petits
morceaux à la macromolécule c'est un peu
pour passer justement de la brique ou de
quelques pierres jusqu'à la cathédrale
et ça ne se fait pas comme ça du jour au
lendemain
[Musique]
pour comprendre comment tout a commencé
il faut faire un grand voyage il y a 4
milliards d'années dans cet enfer la
Terre primitive
[Musique]
puis d'astéroïdes des volcans crachant
leur lave un océan bouillant une
atmosphère irrespirable 100 000 fois
plus riche que la nôtre en dioxyde de
carbone
en 2008 dans un film d'animation au
style volontairement naïf des chercheurs
du CNRS se sont amusés à populariser ce
qu'on peut savoir aujourd'hui sur les
tous premiers temps de la vie
et ils ont choisi de nous compter les
aventures d'une petite molécule d'eau
piccolina
arrivé sur Terre à bord d'une comète
piccolina va assister à la naissance de
la vie dans les océans primitifs
tout d'abord elle voit passer des
molécules isolées et simples comme le
méthane ou le dioxyde de carbone puis
des molécules plus complexes comme les
acides aminés les fameuses briques de
stanleyminer
et si un jour piccolina fait une
rencontre étonnante
un jour je suis tombée nezanée avec une
sorte d'énormes serpent moléculaire un
polymère
des dizaines de molécules s'étaient
accrochées à la queue Leleu quel drôle
d'idées
j'en croisais d'autres de plus en plus
les sortir d'une fissure au fond de la
main où j'étais tombé
j'ai voulu en avoir le cœur net je me
suis approchée et là quel spectacle
des molécules de la même famille
accrochés sur des cristaux d'argile se
rongeaient les unes à côté des autres
en fait ce petit voyage là qu'elle nous
raconte
ça montre la complexification de la
matière on parle de petite molécules
avec du carbone la plupart des atomes de
carbone dans leur structure et ces
molécules elles ont appropriété de se
complexifier de réagir les unes sur les
autres de devenir de plus en plus grosse
ça grossit ça grossit ça devient des
molécules géantes que les chimistes
appellent des macromolécules et parmi
ces macromolécules certaines vont avoir
la propriété de se répliquer de faire
des copies d'elles-mêmes et lorsque ces
premières molécules géantes capables de
se répliquer sont arrivés et bien c'est
la vie on peut dire que c'est
macromolécules qui font des copies
d'elles-mêmes et bien c'est le premier
système vivant
[Musique]
et c'est comme ça peut-être que la vie a
commencé sur d'autres planètes tournant
autour d'autres étoiles pour allumer la
mèche quelques conditions simples
suffisent
si on claquant de ce qui s'est passé sur
terre qui reste la référence dans ce
domaine et bien il sent qu'il y ait
trois éléments indispensables qui sont
la matière carbonée l'eau liquide et des
sources d'énergie
et en fait quand on allait chercher la
vie ailleurs dans le système solaire
pour commencer on va s'intéresser à des
environnements ou ces trois conditions
ou ces trois ces trois ingrédients sont
présents
si ces trois conditions sont présentes
alors tout est possible sur notre
planète même on peut alors trouver la
vie dans les milieux les plus extrêmes
par exemple on découvre une vie dans les
fonds sous-marins à très forte pression
et là on a des systèmes vivants qu'on
appelle des barophiles parce que bah
refilent comme forte pression qui aime
la les fortes pressions dans des lacs où
les selles sont très concentrées la Mer
Morte par exemple la concentration de
sel est à son maximum on a découvert et
on s'y attendait pas au départ on a
découvert aussi plein d'organismes c'est
ce qu'on appelle des des allophiles il y
a des organismes cela sont doutes les
plus extraordinaires sont les
hyperthermophiles qui aiment les très
haute température et le record dans le
domaine pour l'instant c'est 121 degrés
arrêtons-nous là
nous connaissons maintenant les règles
du jeu de la vie
nous voyons sur notre terre seul tous
les vantail des possibilités
[Musique]
or sur des mondes lointains cet éventail
peut encore s'élargir jusqu'à
concurrencer les créations les plus
folles de la science-fiction
à présent allons plus loin
voici le Space need de Seattle dans
l'état de Washington le point de repère
le plus représentatif de la ville
à l'unité de Washington nous découvrons
un étonnant laboratoire
le Virtual planet
[Musique]
ici les exobiologistes modélisent des
mondes virtuels qui aideront les
astronomes à mieux comprendre ce qu'il
découvre dans leur télescope
récemment ils se sont posés une question
toute simple qu'elle pourrait-elle la
couleur de la végétation sur des mondes
orbitants autour de soleil lointain
verte et bien pas forcément
sur notre planète
réfléchissent
sur une planète qui graviterait autour
d'une étoile très chaude
qui diffuserait une lumière très bleue
c'est le bleu qui serait réfléchi par
les plans à l'oeil nu comme au télescope
[Musique]
un homme ça et oui sur l'écran nous
avons du noir
le noir absorbe toutes les couleurs
à côté d'une étoile froide
la végétation absorberait toute la
lumière disponible
ne réfléchirait rien elle a besoin
le noir dominerait l'ensemble du paysage
on aurait donc des planètes sombres avec
des jungles noirs
[Musique]
ces simulations peuvent être étendues à
des formes de vie adaptées à des
conditions très différentes des nôtres
par exemple une planète géante ou la
gravité serait bien plus importante que
sur la terre
[Musique]
une planète à forte gravité retiendrait
davantage son atmosphère au contraire
une planète comme la terre a perdu son
hydrogène ce qui lui a permis de former
la couche d'ozone sur une planète à
forte gravité nous n'aurions pas d'ozone
cela obligerait les plantes ou les
organismes à trouver le moyen de se
protéger du rayonnement ultraviolet
une façon d'y parvenir c'est de vivre au
fond des océans ou alors pour s'adapter
à une forte gravité la vie formerait des
communautés agglomérées comme ces
organismes fossiles qu'on appelle les
stromatolites
mais bien sûr ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la vie intelligente
[Musique]
il suffit d'imaginer l'expérience
inverse
imaginons des extraterrestres qui ont
observé la terre ils ont vu qu'il y
avait des terres émergées de la mer des
plantes de l'air ils vont imaginer des
formes de vie vous une forme de vie
adaptée à ces conditions dans leur
logique
qu'ils vont arriver si par hasard ils
arrivent ils vont trouver un
foisonnement complet de la vie avec des
plantes des animaux des bactéries ils
vont trouver des éléphants des girafes
des mouches des oiseaux des formes de
vie extrêmement différentes qui
partagent en fait le même biotope la
même petite unité et donc on s'aperçoit
qu'il est quand même un peu vain de
vouloir supposer des formes la forme que
prendra la vie simplement à partir des
données physiques et chimiques que l'on
peut observer sur la planète considérée
donc si un jour on a la chance de
trouver une vie extraterrestre si on a
la chance de pouvoir la rencontrer
d'abord elle ne sera pas unique et dans
tous les cas on sera surpris alors
dans la vie oui sans doute mais
l'intelligence
en 1961 un radio astronome célèbre Frank
Drake a proposé une équation pour tenter
d'estimer le nombre potentiel de
civilisations extraterrestres dans notre
galaxie et voici ce que ça donne
ses frais pas c'est une équation très
simple combinant le nombre de planètes
ou la vie est apparue le nombre de
planètes où elle a évolué vers
l'intelligence le nombre de
civilisations capables de communiquer
pour les pessimistes le résultat se
ramène seulement à 1
une seule civilisation
la nôtre
[Musique]
mais pour les optimistes il y en aurait
plusieurs milliers
la tendance optimiste on la trouve
aujourd'hui dans la belle ville
d'Edimbourg en Écosse
dans la bibliothèque de l'Observatoire
royal nous avons rencontré un jeune
chercheur Duncan Ford qui a surpris son
monde en estimant le nombre probable de
civilisations intelligente dans notre
galaxie
pour réaliser ce calcul Duncan forgan a
pu avoir accès au supercalculateur de
l'université qui a travaillé pendant une
dizaine de jours soit un peu plus de 200
heures sur trois scénarios possibles
dans le premier scénario nous sommes
partis de l'hypothèse que la vie
apparaît avec beaucoup de difficultés
sur une planète et qu'elle ne parvient
pas aisément à évoluer vers
l'intelligence
nos modèles informatiques donne un
résultat de 361 planètes dotées d'une
vie intelligente dans une galaxie d'un
milliard d'étoiles
[Musique]
et estime que la vie apparaît plus
facilement que dans le premier scénario
produites par ces formes de vie sont
régulés par un principe sociologique
élémentaire plus une civilisation met de
temps a évolué vers un état avancé de
stabilité plus elle est exposée au
risque de l'autodestruction sous l'écrou
de ses propres technologies
dans ce scénario tu nous arrivons à un
total de 31000 513 civilisations
intelligentes pour une galaxie d'un
milliard d'étoiles
[Musique]
le dernier scénario repose sur une
dissémination de la vie dans la galaxie
par les comètes et les astéroïdes
résultat
964 formes de vie intelligentes
évidemment la question est où sont-ils
le problème réside apparemment dans le
fait que si deux civilisations peuvent
exister dans l'espace elle n'existe pas
forcément au même moment dans le temps
or il faut que ces deux critères soient
réunis pour espérer un contact entre ces
deux civilisations
admettons pourtant que quelques-unes de
ces civilisations vivent à la même
époque que nous
à quoi pourrait-elle alors ressembler
en 1964 l'astronome russe Nicolas et
kardashev a proposé de les classer en
fonction de leur consommation d'énergie
d'abord il y a les civilisations de type
1 elle survivent en exploitant toute
l'énergie de leur planète
mais nous en sommes encore très loin il
nous faudra attendre sans doute
plusieurs siècles pour devenir une
véritable civilisation de Type 1
les civilisations de type 2 sont
beaucoup plus avancés mais beaucoup plus
rares elles exploitent toute l'énergie
de leur étoile
voici comment on pourrait les imaginer
un gigantesque ensemble d'un anneau d'un
milliard de kilomètres de diamètre
édifier autour d'un soleil étranger mais
comparable aux autres
ce fantastique anneau permette à la
super civilisation de collecter toute
l'énergie de son étoile environ 100 000
milliards de milliards de kilowatts pour
une étoile
identique à notre Soleil
à l'intérieur de ces structures vivent
des millions de peuples dans des
habitats façonnés à leurs gris
bien sûr les civilisations de type 2 ont
des millions d'années d'avance sur la
nôtre elle maîtrise sans doute le voyage
interstellaire et des technologies dont
nous n'avons pas la moindre idée
enfin il y
a civilisation de Type 3 elles
exploitent toute l'énergie de leur
galaxie elles auraient un ou plusieurs
milliards d'années d'avance sur nous
[Musique]
oui mais encore une fois où sont-ils
normalement de telles civilisations
devraient émettre des signaux radio que
nous pourrions capter grâce à nos
radiotélescopes c'est le but du célèbre
projet Setty littéralement recherche
d'une intelligence extraterrestre le
problème c'est que pour l'instant le
ciel reste
nous voici à San Francisco
nous prenons immédiatement la direction
du sud vers la petite ville de Mountain
View qui abrite le quartier général de
l'association Setti
ici inlassablement on scrute le ciel en
quête d'un signal radio un signal
intelligent émis par une civilisation
extraterrestre
oui mais 50 ans ont passé et toujours
rien comment comprendre ce silence
[Musique]
le bon métier
ma réponse c'est oui évidemment car si
on a encore rien trouvé nos techniques
progresses elle double de rythme tous
les 18 mois environ et donc quoi qu'il
arrive cela représentera dans deux ans
une saisie de données plus importante
que celle collectée dans les 50
dernières années
c'est cela qui me pousse à poursuivre je
suis persuadé que les 20 ans qui
viennent nous apporteront beaucoup
[Musique]
j'ai une surprise pour vous un message
capté par le radiotélescope de Nancy
pour une surprise s'en était une ce
message avait été reçu quelques jours
auparavant par le radio télescope de
Nancy en Sologne
principalement destiné à l'exploration
du ciel ce puissant radio télescope sert
aussi marginalement accepté d'éventuels
signaux radio intelligents
et voici d'abord ce qui a attiré
l'attention des chercheurs
ça c'est le spectre des ondes radio
qu'on reçoit avec le radiotélescope de
nancet et là ce pic représente le signal
intelligent que l'on peut attendre d'une
civilisation extraterrestre il est
extrêmement fin là on le voit varier
il disparaître c'est la présence et
l'absence de ce signal qui peut indiquer
un codage en l'occurrence le voici
revenu
on peut imaginer que c'est un signal
binaire une suite de 0 de 1 et qu'il
faut ensuite décoder
voici le message transcrit en binaire
une suite de 0 et de 1 mais qui obéit à
une logique cachée si on compte les
chiffres on en trouve 583 et 583 on sait
que c'est 11 x 53 donc on a rangé ces
chiffres et voilà ce qu'on obtient 53
lignes et 11 colonnes et on obtient
comme un petit dessin
pour comprendre la suite il faut revenir
36 ans en arrière en 1974 avec le
puissant radio télescope d'un récipro
installé à Porto Rico les astronomes
avaient envoyé vers l'espace ce salut
aux étoiles contenant des informations
sur nos autres terriens les nombres de 1
à 10
les numéros atomiques de quelques atomes
et même un croquis de l'être humain et
sa taille et puis d'autres précisions du
même genre
et à présent on pourrait supposer que ce
message a été capté par des êtres
intelligents qui ne l'ont renvoyé un peu
modifié donc là on retrouve ce qu'on
envoyait à recibeau c'est-à-dire que là
on a des chiffres 1 2 3 4 5 6 donc
peut-être que c'était envoyé par
quelqu'un qui compte en bassiste et par
exemple qui aurait 6 doigts là on a
comme une étoile peut-être et des
planètes autour donc là on continue six
planètes et on remarque que le la
quatrième est un peu décalé donc ils
habitent certainement sur la 4e planète
donc voilà à quoi il pourrait ressembler
et là on a certainement le
radiotélescope qui leur a permis soit de
recevoir soit d'envoyer ce message
à partir de là que faisons-nous comment
annoncer la nouvelle au monde
l'association City qui a réfléchit
depuis longtemps à cette question a mis
au point un protocole très précis
on pense généralement que la première
personne qu'il faudrait t'informer de la
réception d'un tel message devrait être
le président de la République française
et si c'était les Américains qui
captaient un tel message il devrait
informer leur présidente mais pour le
protocole Setty les messages
extraterrestres ne sont nullement
destinés à un pays particulier il soit
adressé à la terre en tant que telle et
sont la propriété de la terre tout
entière
en cas de réception d'un signal
l'article 1 du protocole SETI prévoit
des mesures très simples d'abord
vérifier que ce message est
véritablement d'origine extraterrestre
car il ne faut pas propager une erreur
la deuxième chose sera d'annoncée à tous
les astronomes du monde qu'un signal a
été reçu de tels coins du ciel et qu'il
faut braquer les télescopes sur cette
zone chacun parlera aux autres tout le
monde sera mis au courant puis entreront
en jeu les médias l'opinion publique les
gouvernements etc
maintenant si nous voulons répondre à ce
message partons de ce constat très clair
les extraterrestres semblent très
intéressés par la forme humaine qui est
peut-être d'ailleurs leur propre forme
ce qui nous donnerait quelque chose en
commun on pourrait donc leur envoyer une
réponse de ce type nous partirons de la
même image de cette formule humaine
figurant dans le message reçu et nous
allons leur faire savoir que notre corps
possède différentes parties oui on va
centrer le message sur cette partie nous
avons des bras et ses bras peuvent
bouger puis nous reviendrons encore
complets où nous ferons un gros plan sur
par exemple noum
pour leur expliquer que nous avons cinq
doigts
sur notre visage ce à quoi il ressemble
voici un visage humain
nous ouvrons sur un œil pour leur
montrer que c'est pour nous un organe
très important qui n'est pas statique
qui s'ouvre qui se ferme
etc
il s'agirait en définitif de leur faire
savoir que nous avons bien reçu leur
message et qu'en retour nous leur
adressons un message de bienvenue
et bien sûr hélas tout cela n'était
qu'une simulation pour l'instant encore
une fois nous n'avons rien reçu alors
question et si nous étions seuls
absolument seul dans l'univers
parmi toutes les planètes qui existent
dans notre galaxie probablement des
millions et des millions toutes ne sont
certainement pas intéressantes au regard
de la vie mais quelques-unes sont
certainement et cela dans notre seul
galaxie or il y a des centaines de
milliards d'autres galaxies chacune
composée d'au moins un milliard de
planètes alors vraiment penser que notre
planète serait la seule planète
possédant une vie intelligente dans
l'univers ce serait ça le miracle et
franchement en tant que chercheur j'ai
appris à ne pas croire aux miracles
[Musique]
et pourtant du côté des pessimistes qui
ne croient pas aux miracles on trouve le
biologiste Peter World auteur d'un livre
bombe
la terre rare selon lui la vie abonde
dans l'univers mais l'intelligence est
rare et peut-être même unique
nous serions donc seuls
mais pas pour toujours
la question à mes yeux n'est pas tant
d'être seul et si nous étions les
premiers peut-être sommes-nous après
tout la première intelligence à
atteindre le stade du savoir-faire
technique mieux encore si nous étions la
graine qui permettra à l'humanité de se
propager sur d'autres planètes ou
d'autres galaxies oui cela serait une
vraie raison d'être optimiste en plus
cela serait tout simplement merveilleux
plus que jamais il faut se rappeler que
l'échelle de l'univers n'est pas la
nôtre
il nous faut donc rester patient
attendre combien de temps nul ne le sait
mais pour certains d'ici 10 ans nous
aurons la réponse et ce jour-là pour
l'humanité tout va basculer
[Musique]
et finalement vous l'avez compris
l'univers est immense dans l'espace
comme dans le temps depuis sa naissance
il y a 13,7 milliards d'années époque
lointaine à laquelle toute la réalité du
monde primordiale proposée sur quelques
éléments seulement étonnamment seul
l'univers a donc atteint une fabuleuse
complexité depuis le commencement des
temps les puissants constantes
d'universels les mystérieuses lois
physiques enfouies dans leur brume
mathématique étrange incontournable
allez se mettre au travail et régler la
matière pour la conduire coûte que coûte
vers la vie et si un beau jour on finit
par découvrir que la vie existe ailleurs
que sur Terre alors ce jour-là on saura
que dans l'univers rien n'est impossible
[Musique]
oui je crois qu'on peut applaudir le
film de Grichka et Gorg Bogdanov parce
que il a le mérite de nous sortir de ce
que nous voyons traditionnellement dans
les chaînes de télévision et on en
parlait tout à l'heure quel dommage que
l'on ne donne pas à des scientifiques
qui ont ce niveau et cette capacité de
vulgarisation cette porte ouverte sur
nos esprits alors avant que on engage le
dialogue je voudrais juste faire une ou
deux réflexions puisque
je viens moi-même de terminer avec
Jean-Pierre Petit que certains d'entre
vous connaissent qui est un ancien
directeur de recherche au CNRS notre
deuxième livre qui s'appelle contact
cosmique
jusqu'où peut-on penser trop loin mon
sentiment mon sentiment ça fait 50 ans
que je travaille sur ce dossier
mon sentiment c'est évidemment la vie
foisonne dans l'univers
évidemment la vie intelligente beaucoup
beaucoup plus intelligente que la nôtre
foisonne dans l'univers et pourquoi
est-ce que j'avance cette phrase qui
peut peut-être se surprendre certains
d'entre vous
c'est parce que il suffit de regarder
les chiffres qui ont été donnés par Igor
et Grichka il y a un instant nous sommes
sur une planète qui se refroidit
progressivement
[Musique]
et qui a 4 milliards et demi d'années
l'univers
théorie du Big Bang théorie qui
peut-être bouleversée par une nouvelle
découverte à 13 milliards 800 millions
d'années 14 milliards d'années
arrondissons
c'est-à-dire que des vies ont pu naître
sur d'autres planètes près de 10
milliards d'années avant
nos propres vies donc vous imaginez bien
non vous ne pouvez pas imaginer ce que
serait une vie qui aurait ne serait-ce
qu'un million d'années d'avance par
rapport à la nôtre or il y a des
milliers de milliards de planètes sur
lesquelles la vie a pu naître des
millions ou des milliards d'années avant
notre propre vie donc évidemment ce sont
des chiffres astronomiques comme on le
dit a juste titre
et ça fait réfléchir
[Musique]
puisque je travaille depuis 30 ans sur
la religion juive la religion chrétienne
la religion musulmane et toutes ces
religions nous indiquent qu'il y a
quelques milliers d'années quelque chose
descendu du ciel
est venu que nos ancêtres ont pris pour
Dieu si vous avez la Bible chez vous qui
est reconnue par évidemment les juifs
les chrétiens mais aussi les musulmans
vous lirez dans la Genèse chapitre 6 Les
Fils de Dieu
trouvèrent les filles de la terre à leur
goût se traduit différemment selon les
quatre traductions et eurent commerce
avec elle et leur firent des enfants
ce qui veut dire que ceux qui ne croient
pas la vie extraterrestre
ils ont peut-être en eux-mêmes dans leur
propre ADN un bouddaden venu des étoiles
voilà alors
Igor
et Grichka après avoir ouvert cette
petite porte
ésotérique co scientifique je voudrais
vous demander parce que ça va une telle
vitesse
où en êtes-vous aujourd'hui dans votre
appréciation de la vie intelligente dans
l'univers car en six ans tout a été
balayé bouleversé tout a été balayé à ce
point que les chiffres qui ont été
donnés en 2011 ont été multipliées de
façon vertigineuse en 2011 on parlait de
400 planètes découvertes dans l'univers
y compris les planètes gazeuses
aujourd'hui Jean-Claude l'a dit on en
compte plus de 4000 donc vous voyez
l'extraordinaire développement de du
nombre de planètes découvertes et
observées quand je dis découvert ça veut
dire vous avez eu vous avez pu découvrir
la manière dont les scientifiques
procèdent pour établir avec certitude
l'existence d'autres planètes ailleurs
que sur la terre sur des systèmes
solaires commencent on en a découvert
qu'une encore récemment il y a pas très
très longtemps qui est alpha Santori B
Alpha du Centaure c'est c'est une
planète c'est une une étoile qui est
très intéressante parce que c'est un
système triple de trois étoiles qui
gravitent les unes autour des autres
mais il est intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'il est très proche de la THC le plus
proche système solaire de la terre il
est situé à 4 années et deux mois
lumière de de notre système solaire donc
c'est c'est très près ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que si Grichka ou
Jean-Claude
ont la belle idée d'aller visiter la
planète que l'on vient de découvrir et
qui qui gravitent au contour du soleil
principal c'est cette planète s'appelle
alpha Centris B elle est située à bonne
distance elle est juste à la distance
convenable pour recueillir une énergie
suffisante pour déclencher la vie elle
est nique trop chaude ni trop froide et
elle est une planète solide terre comme
la terre qui est une planète solide
c'est pas une planète gazeuse et bien si
Jean-Claude avait la belle idée de se
rendre sur cette planète et bien on
pourrait communiquer bon ça prendrait un
petit peu de temps mais si je demande à
à grisca qui est sur place ou à
Jean-Claude alors que Jean-Claude vous
êtes là-bas vous êtes vous êtes sur alfa
century
combien de temps à votre avis puisque
j'ai dit la distance combien de temps à
votre avis il faudra-t-il attendre pour
que Grichka ou Jean-Claude
recueille mon message et me répondre
allez
combien
ben voilà 4 ans exactement 4 ans et un
petit peu plus mais en effet 4 ans un
petit peu plus de 4 ans pour que je
reçois ensemble avec Jean-Claude sur
cette planète on la découvre sur Alpha
du Centaure donc B et bien 4 ans pour
que je dise
quelque chose qui sera une réponse oui
nous sommes arrivés nous sommes sur un
monde qui est très froid qui est sombre
mais sur lequel nous pouvons malgré tout
nous déplacer la gravité y est presque
semblable à la gravité sur terre donc
nous sommes à peine un petit peu plus
léger
Igor va attendre un petit peu plus de 4
ans la réponse donc entre l'allée et le
retour
il faudra un petit peu plus de 8 ans 8
ans et demi pour que nous puissions
communiquer cela dit ça vous paraît
beaucoup huit ans pour un effet
communiqué dire allô ça va oui bien sûr
bien reçu c'est beaucoup mais c'est très
très peu
si on compare l'échelle de ce qui se
passe à la galaxie sur la galaxie juste
pour vous donner une idée puisque nous
sommes à 40000 milliards de kilomètres
d'Alpha du Centaure en milliard de
kilomètres ça fait beaucoup mais en
année lumière ça fait très peu juste
pour que vous ayez en tête ce qu'est une
année lumière mais les lumières c'est
9000 milliards de kilomètres mais ça va
très vite la lumière la lumière ici les
photons qui se déplacent dans cette
pièce et bien ces photons se déplacent
quand même à pratiquement 300 000 km à
la seconde c'est à dire cette fois le
tour de la terre en une seconde
cette fois le tour de la terre à chaque
seconde et pourtant cette vitesse
vertigineuse il leur faut 4 ans pour
aller sur le plus proche planète de
notre système solaire
et il leur faudra beaucoup plus pour
aller aux limites de la galaxie car si
on veut se déplacer jusque à la
frontière de notre galaxie qui est un
immense nuage d'étoiles en forme
lenticulaire
et bien il nous faudra en fait depuis
chez nous à peu près 80 000 ans
80 000 ans de sorte que si je vais aux
limites de la galaxie
et que
Igor me pose la question
je vais attendre 80 000 ans
à la vitesse de la lumière avec mon
téléphone portable c'est un téléphone
portable qui me permet de communiquer je
peux communiquer n'importe où avec ça et
bien
80.000 ans quand même alors que je suis
dans la banlieue de l'univers c'est
juste tout à côté c'est notre galaxie 80
000 ans
pour attendre qu'il me disent est-ce que
tu es bien arrivé et moi je dirais mais
oui je suis à la frontière de la galaxie
ça y est j'y suis
il faudra quand même qu'il dort attendre
80 000 ans
pour avoir la réponse que je viens de
lui donner pour l'aller-retour d'un côté
à l'autre de la conversation il faudra
160 000 ans
et ceci à la vitesse de la lumière vous
voyez donc les échelles si je dois aller
un petit peu plus loin quitter notre
galaxie la Voie lactée et aller vers
la magnifique grande galaxie d'Andromède
qui était photographiée
au début du 20e siècle
par des premiers premiers astronomes qui
ont découvert les premières galaxies
extérieures notre
notre galaxie à nous parce que jusqu'en
1900 sachez que jusqu'en 1925 très
exactement on pensait que notre galaxie
était la seule la seule dans tout
l'univers
et même des grands astronomes comme
Flammarion comme dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais Einstein lui-même qui avait
pourtant dès 1915
construit découvert ce magnifique
édifice qu'on appelle la relativité
générale
bien même lui pensait que il n'y avait
qu'une seule galaxie
l'anneau et rien d'autre
et pourtant un jeune astronome en 1925
brillant un astronome qui aurait dû
devenir d'après ce que ses parents
voulaient faire de lui
soit éventuellement un grand sportif
pouvait devenir champion de basketball
très important aux États-Unis ou bien
peut-être professeur d'espagnol
il s'appelle
connaissez tous son nom
Edwin bravo
évidemment 50 ans on voit que le niveau
bravo et bien humble en 1925 donne un
cadeau à l'humanité et vous savez quel
jour il choisit pour te faire ce cadeau
sublime il choisit le 31 décembre
1925 au lieu d'être avec ses amis pour
faire la fête et célébrer à
Saint-Sylvestre il est dans son
observatoire et il va communiquer au
monde entier cette nouvelle
extraordinaire notre galaxie n'est pas
la seule non il y en a d'autres et c'est
lui qui a photographié la magnifique
merveilleuse galaxie sœur
exactement semblable à un autre avec
probablement le même nombre d'étoiles à
peine plus grosse la galaxie d'Andromède
et cette galaxie d'Andromède avec ces
300 milliards d'étoiles état un peu plus
de 2 et quelques années lumière si bien
que 2 millions et demi admettons quand
on est au centre et bien si bien que si
je vais là-bas
je dis à Igor ça y est je suis sur la
galaxie voisine de la terre je suis sur
Andromède
et bien
Igor va attendre plus de 2 millions
d'années plus de 2 millions d'années
ce signal que je lui donne et puis s'il
me dit quel temps est-ce qu'il fait
là-bas
j'aurais également attendre 2 millions
et 300000 années avant d'avoir sa
réponse donc 5 millions d'années pour un
aller-retour
et ce n'est encore rien mes amis parce
que quand on parle de la galaxie
d'Andromède nous sommes chez nous encore
c'est ce que les astronomes appellent le
groupe local c'est à dire c'est vraiment
c'est la localité c'est la banlieue
c'est la banlieue du système solaire
la banlieue parce que la galaxie
d'Andromède elle fait partie de ce
troupeau il y a à peu près une vingtaine
de galaxies qui font partie de cet amas
local dont nous sommes dans la Voie
Lactée fait partie donc vous en avez un
certain nombre une trentaine qui sont
dans un petit volume mais on doit aller
beaucoup plus loin alors je peux aller
100 millions d'années-lumière de chez
nous je peux aller à 500 millions
d'années-lumières de chez nous je peux
aller à un milliard d'années-lumière de
chez nous je peux aller à 5 milliards
d'années-lumière de chez nous
et la conversation là prendra 10
milliards d'années
vous voyez le gigantisme de l'univers
alors quand on nous dit
il est probable que nous sommes les
seuls vous avez vu ce qu'on dit les
scientifiques ils se sont pratiquement
révoltés contre cette idée que nous
serions les seuls alors que les
milliards de milliards de possibilités
existent partout dans l'univers
donc nous sommes privilégiés puisque
nous sommes dans un certain stade où
nous commençons à comprendre à cette
époque nous avons de la chance de vivre
ce début du 21e siècle parce que nous
sommes contemporains de la découverte
que en effet il est probable que nous ne
sommes pas seuls dans l'Univers et
au-delà de ça nous avons une bonne
nouvelle à partager avec vous
j'en parlais tout à l'heure avec Thierry
la bonne nouvelle
en ce début de 21e siècle
c'est que va être lancé bientôt un
satellite qui s'appelle James web on en
parlait pas encore à cette époque-là
quand vous avez évidemment dans ce film
vu un certain nombre de satellite mais
il n'y avait pas encore il était
simplement un progrès ou un projet
il n'y avait pas encore de possibilités
de parler clairement de ce futur
satellite qui va être lancé dans
quelques mois par la NASA ce sera au
tour des années 2020
et ce satellite figurez-vous il est
destiné
à recueillir à détecter à détecter les
premières
on va dire trace ou plutôt
signaux des premiers signaux
de l'existence de la vie sur d'autres
mondes alors comment ce qui va s'y
prendre si par exemple autour de
Saint-Quentin il y a à peu près une
vingtaine de kilomètres d'ici il y a des
prairies dans ces prairies il y a des
vaches
et bien c'est vache c'est troupeau
et bien il se dégage des troupeaux en
question
tout le monde le sait aujourd'hui on
sait que l'indice carbone est augmenté
par les formes de vie dans par exemple
une prairie et bien
que va faire ce satellite il va tenter
de détecter
sur d'autres mondes qui vont être
choisis des planètes qui seront
semblables à la Terre ni trop près ni
trop loin de leur soleil qui auront de
l'eau et on sait exactement détecter
maintenant les planètes qui ont de l'eau
et donc des traces carbonées vous avez
vu la recette pour faire la vie il faut
du carbone il faut de l'eau
et c'est à peu près tout à partir de là
si on a une source d'énergie c'est à
dire le soleil qui est à la bonne
distance et bien le four biologique que
représente une planète va engendrer la
vie mais voilà il faut la détecter cette
vie et bien grâce à ce satellite on va
faire exactement comme on ferait depuis
l'extérieur du système solaire pour
regarder ce qui se passe sur terre
on va
scruter et détecter des manifestations
organiques par exemple le CO2 mais il y
en a d'autres il y a aussi le méthane
qu'on appelle le gaz des marais des
marais il y a aussi le benzène tout ce
que vous avez peut-être le souvenir de
ce qu'on appelle la chimie organique ils
n'ont pas la chimie minérale qui elle
aussi existe et sera repéré mais ce qui
compte pour ce satellite c'est la chimie
organique
c'est-à-dire une chimie qui est tout
près de la vie et c'est comme ça qu'on
espère d'ici pas très longtemps
d'ici pas très longtemps détecter des
formes de vie
avec leur signature leur signature
incontestable et c'est pour ça que tous
les trois là ce soir nous prenons un
pari
le pari est le suivant c'est que nous
revenions ici
dans 5 ans
et dans 5 ans
j'en fais le pari
nous serons maintenant cette même salle
avec un cadeau comme en 1925 ce sera
aller en 2025 100 ans plus tard
et bien le cadeau c'est oui mes amis il
existe aujourd'hui une preuve
irréfutable que la vie existe ailleurs
dans l'univers on l'a détecté on l'a en
quelque sorte observé grâce à nos
instruments c'est pour ça que je disais
tout à l'heure que nous avons de la
chance oui quelle chance inouïe cette
spéculation s'est interrogation si
radicale si profonde philosophiquement
si riche parce que c'est vrai que ça
touche beaucoup beaucoup de choses pas
simplement évidemment du point de vue
scientifique mais dans nos vies dans nos
consciences dans nos consciences
spirituelles de savoir que nous ne
sommes pas seuls
que ses cousins qui sont évidemment sur
le même principe
VTS sur le même principe biologique que
nous existe ailleurs j’entamine par là
en disant principes biologique mais
pourquoi parce que il n'y a pas 36
filières pour la vie
il y a une filière extrêmement
n'existe pas du tout dans l'univers qui
est filière du silicium
donc des organismes qui vivraient dans
de l'ammoniac qui est respirait dans des
conditions qui sont absurdes ne peuvent
pas évoluer donc ce n'est pas possible
que la vie se développe à partir du
silice ou silicium en dehors des
ordinateurs d'ailleurs qui eux
prospèrent sur le silicium mais c'est
tout
la vie elle existe à partir du carbone
vous avez entendu le professeur Rollin
qui l'a dit très clairement il y a trois
éléments il nous faut de l'eau il nous
faut du carbone et une source d'énergie
un soleil et à partir de là la vie
apparaît mais donc c'est une vie qui est
fondée sur le cycle de carbone tous les
organismes terrestres sont nos cousins
ils sont basés exactement sur ce cycle
le cycle du carbone il n'y a pas
d'autres filières pour la vie sur Terre
et c'est très probablement ce qui existe
ailleurs parce que précisément sur ce
pose la question vous avez vu tout à
l'heure question qui ont été soulevées
par les exos biologistes
quel type de vie peut-il exister là-haut
là-bas au loin et bien vraisemblablement
comme tous les éléments chimiques dans
la fameuse table périodique des éléments
dont vous avez évidemment étudié toutes
les ressources quand vous étiez sur les
bancs de l'école il y a pas si longtemps
et bien tous ces éléments chimiques
donnent lieu à des éléments biochimiques
notamment le cycle du carbone qui sont
partout les mêmes donc il est
vraisemblable que nous pouvons dire
véritablement ce sont nos cousins
la vie
ressemblera d'une manière ou d'une autre
et nous nous avons
Igor et moi une croyance que je crois
partager par Jean-Claude ici c'est que
finalement
il existe un théorème de convergence des
formes de la vie et que la vie
intelligente des très grandes chances de
ressembler à la forme humanoïde très
grande chance même si elle évolue de
très loin pour des raisons qui sont
profondes et qui sont évidemment
partagées par la plupart des
exobiologistes aujourd'hui
quelle bonne nouvelle
quelle bonne nouvelle de penser que nous
ne sommes pas seuls et que ses cousins
là qui sont très certainement en avance
sur nous pour certains d'autres sont en
retard parce que la vie n'apparaît pas
exactement
disons que la vie a des chances
d'apparaître au même moment partout mais
elle n'évolue pas au même rythme pour
des questions qui sont liées
l'environnement donc certains ont pris
de l'avance ils ont probablement 1000
ans 2000 ans 3000 ans
10 000 ans d'avance
est-ce que vous pouvez vous représenter
ce que sera 50 ans dans 10 000 ans
quand je pense que dans ma poche là
j'ai aujourd'hui un téléphone qui
concentre qui est à 512 giga octet mais
ça veut dire quoi 512 Go ça veut dire
que là dans cette toute petite surface
ce tout petit volume
et bien j'ai
512000 volumes livres de 1000 pages
chacun
512000 livres de mille pages
ceci représente pour l'instant la pointe
de
ce qu'on appelle la révolution numérique
dans notre poche
dans un an dans deux ans hier nous
étions
Igor et moi un sommet du numérique qu'on
appelle
qui regroupait donc
tous les acteurs du numérique
aujourd'hui
les grands acteurs vous savez les gafas
c'est-à-dire donc Google Amazon Facebook
et puis tous les autres
il y avait IBM il y avait tous les tous
les tous les grands
tous les grands Microsoft les autres qui
dominent aujourd'hui
la planète il faut dire que ce sont eux
les géants qui transforment le monde à
une vitesse colossale hier le savoir
scientifique quand je dis hier c'était
il y a 5 ans il doublait tous les ans
aujourd'hui le savoir scientifique
double tous les trois mois
demain c'est à dire en 2020 il doublera
toutes les quatre semaines
pourquoi parce que les machines à
traiter l'information sont de plus en
plus efficaces et ce n'est encore rien
quand on verra apparaître à l'horizon 4
ans j'en parlais hier avec les
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle qui était là dans ce petit
congrès et bien
dans quatre ans cinq ans vont apparaître
les premiers ordinateurs quantiques les
premiers ordinateurs quantiques
calculeront encore mille fois plus vite
que les ordinateurs actuels c'est-à-dire
ce que fait un ordinateur en mille jours
donc il faut à peu près aller 3 ans pour
calculer
en une seule journée en 12 heures
l'ordinateur quantique obtiendra le même
résultat et alors là le savoir
scientifique il doublera non pas tous
les toutes les quatre semaines mais
toutes les quatre heures
voilà
ce que nous promet le progrès
scientifique et technologique dans
lequel nous vivons donc nous avons la
chance d'être emporté dans cette vague
profitez-en bien parce que vous êtes
vous-même les
témoins certes mais aussi les acteurs
les acteurs concernés on dit que
aujourd'hui la science est compliquée
que il est difficile de faire retour
dans un monde qui dominait par la
science de la technologie qu'on comprend
pas et bien c'est faux
tout à l'heure Jean-Claude disait
quelque chose de très juste c'est il
faut partager ce savoir il faut le vivre
avec allégresse il faut le vivre avec
enthousiasme il faut le vivre avec
optimisme on en parlait tout à l'heure
les optimistes c'est bien nous nous
sommes tous les trois des optimistes et
nous pensons que cette science qui nous
entraîne toujours un petit peu plus vite
et bien elle nous délivre de quelque
chose ce poids de l'ignorance ce poids
qui avait été décrit par George Orwell
en 1984 quand il disait la guerre c'est
la paix l'ignorance c'est c'est
l'esclavage
oui l'esclavage et bien délivrons-nous
de cet esclavage devenons libre et
devenant heureux de contempler ce
magnifique spectacle où la vie se
développe partout dans l'univers de
manière de plus en plus intelligente à
mesure que l'expansion de l'Univers se
poursuit
alors merci infiniment pour ce
développement qui nous ouvre
les étoiles et l'esprit
AGRICA et à Igor une question très
simple et très facile finalement puisque
vous avez dans l'un de vos livres
essayez de passer de l'autre côté du mur
de plans je voudrais vous demander
comment vous voyez
la pulsion originelle du Big Bang quelle
est cette intelligence que certains
appellent Dieu qui a créé l'Univers et
qui s'est manifesté il y a 13,8
milliards d'années puisque selon la
théorie du Big Bang à cette époque-là
l'univers était invisible c'était une
masse infinie avec une température
infinie donc une question très facile
finalement
ah question toute simple alors
Jean-Claude vient de poser finalement la
question
fondamentale fondamental
comment est né notre univers cet univers
que vous avez vu ici dans ces images par
bride
ça s'est passé il y a 13 milliards et
820 millions d'années d'ailleurs
Jean-Claude très informé a dit le
chiffre tout à l'heure
13 milliards 820 millions pourquoi
est-ce que ce chiffre aussi exact parce
que un satellite astronomique qui était
lancé le 14 mai 2009 qui s'appelle le
satellite Planck a observé la lumière la
plus lointaine qui était émise par
l'univers c'était le moment où les
photons les premiers photons s'arrachent
à la matière et où l'univers devient
lumineux ça s'est passé cet événement il
y a exactement 380
000 ans après le Big Bang c'était il y a
13 milliards 820 millions d'années mais
c'était juste un peu plus de 300 000 ans
après le Big Bang après
donc
cet événement qu'on appelle le
découplage de la radiation lumineuse
nous enseigne et nous donne la
possibilité de dater très exactement
très exactement
la naissance de l'Univers l'acte de
naissance le bulletin de naissance 13
milliards 820 millions d'années quand on
remonte en deçà de cette frontière
lumineuse de l'an 380 000 et bien là il
n'y a plus de lumière parce que les
photons sont prisonniers à cause de la
température c'est une température de
l'ordre de 3000 degrés et à cette
température les photons sont prisonniers
de la matière c'est à dire des protons
des électrons etc notamment des protons
alors les protons c'est quoi ce sont des
noyaux et des noyaux de quoi et ben des
noyaux d'atomes d'hydrogène remontons
jusqu'au moment du Big Bang on traverse
cette époque qu'on appelle les âges
sombres c'est comme ça que les
astrophysiciens l'appellent les âges
sombres parce que il y a pas de lumière
il y a pas encore de lumière à cette
époque la lumière n'apparaîtra quand
l'antre 180 000 donc il fait noir et on
remonte
alors que il fait de plus en plus chaud
vers l'origine
quand je dis de plus en plus chaud on va
parler bientôt de millions de degrés
puis de centaines de millions de degrés
il faut que vous sachiez que à la
température du soleil ben c'est très
faible la température du soleil et la
surface elle est juste de 6000 degrés
donc c'est pas beaucoup mais quand vous
êtes dans le cœur du soleil c'est un
petit peu plus c'est 100 millions de
degrés c'est la température de la fusion
thermonucléaire mais c'est pas non plus
énorme parce que quand on va regarder
l'univers très tôt quand on va passer la
barrière des milliers d'années qui nous
séparent du Big Bang on va se trouver
dans des températures de l'ordre de 100
millions 150 millions 200 millions 300
millions de degrés
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive jusqu'à ce qu'on
arrive à la troisième minute écoutez
bien la troisième minute après le Big
Bang
et quelle est la température à ce
moment-là elle est juste 182 donc 180
secondes 3 minutes après le Big Bang
après l'explosion
elle est tout juste de 1 milliard de
degrés quand je dis tout juste c'est
quand même beaucoup par rapport à la
température du soleil c'est 10 fois plus
remontant encore plus loin et remontons
au moment du Big Bang et là la
température est gigantesque puisqu'elle
est de 10 puissance 32 degrés
c'est quoi 10 puissance 32 degrés vous
qui avez fait des mathématiques à
Saint-Quentin on est très fort je le
sais ça vous l'avez démontré tout à
l'heure donc puissance 32 ça veut dire
qu'il y a un suivi de 32 0 les
physiciens sont tous d'accord sur ce
chiffre il en calculé 1832 c'est
10 puissance 100 par exemple c'est
combien de zéro deux 10 puissance 1000
c'est 3 0 10 puissance 9 c'est 9 0 et 9
0 vous savez quand vous calculez vos
revenus à la fin du mois c'est un
milliard d'euros donc c'est donc non
mais sérieusement vous calculez tous
10 puissance 9
un milliard 10 puissance 18 1 milliard
de milliards 10 puissance 27 1 milliard
de milliards de milliards et pour aller
jusqu'à 1832 il fera rajouter encore 5-0
c'est 100000 ce qui nous donne une
température de 100000 milliards de
milliards 2 milliards de degrés alors
ici j'ai de l'eau vous voyez c'est eau
qui est là je la prends
et dans cette eau il y a ce qu'on
appelle vous connaissez la formule de
l'eau quand même tout le monde la
connaît
vous êtes d'accord
vous préférez dire H2O sans doute c'est
mieux dans ce sens là c'est plus facile
donc H2O c'est ici dans chaque molécule
il y a un atome
d'oxygène et un atome d'hydrogène bon
il faut savoir que c'est un mariage de
raison parce que il y a une très grande
différence d'âge entre l'oxygène et
l'hydrogène l'oxygène est des milliards
d'années au 6 milliards d'années
pratiquement plus jeune que l'hydrogène
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
justement
ce premier instant pendant ces trois
premières minutes de vie de l'univers
après le Big Bang
il y a eu comme une explosion de matière
à ce moment-là à cette température
colossale l'explosion de matière elle se
caractérise par un déferlement
inouï incroyable de protons les protons
c'est quoi c'est des noyaux d'atomes
d'hydrogène j'ai dit que là-dedans il y
avait des des protons il y a des protons
là dedans c'est des noyaux d'atomes
d'hydrogène
hydrogène et c'est très simple c'est
juste un proton et un électron qui
tourne autour c'est pour ça que la
formule d'hydrogène c'est h = 1
c'est très simple c'est le nombre
atomique c'est le nombre des électrons
bon donc il est très très simple c'est
de la particule la plus simple de tout
l'univers mais c'est aussi la plus
abondante ce qui est extraordinaire
pour fabriquer vous allez voir pour
fabriquer des noyaux d'atomes
d'hydrogène c'est des protons il faut
que la température du four cosmique soit
très élevé 100000 milliards de milliards
de milliards de degrés et en 3 minutes à
peine cette température chute de manière
dramatique à 1 milliard de degrés et là
le four cosmique est devenu trop froid
pour continuer à fabriquer des noyaux
d'atomes d'hydrogène c'est fini il y en
aura plus jamais plus jamais aucun noyau
d'atomes d'hydrogène n'a été fabriqué
au-delà de la troisième minute
c'est-à-dire que comme l'hydrogène et le
corps le plus abondant et que toute la
masse de l'univers c'est à dire 98%
pratiquement de la masse de tout
l'univers était fabriqué dans ces trois
premières minutes
ça veut dire donc là dedans ces
milliards de milliards de milliards de
noyaux d'atomes d'hydrogène ont été
fabriqués dans les trois premières
minutes de l'univers et plus jamais
après est-ce que vous vous rendez compte
les amis de
l'incroyable ajustement de l'incroyable
précision qu'il a fallu à l'univers pour
fabriquer ce four cosmique 98% de la
matière
de ce qui existe aujourd'hui de toute la
masse qui existe aujourd'hui dans
l'univers parce que c'est de loin le
corps le plus abondant
là dedans là dans cette eau il y a donc
des noyaux de tombes d'hydrogène qui ont
été fabriqués dans les 180 premières
secondes de vie de l'univers et plus
jamais après alors que ce fauteuil lui
les molécules et les atomes qui
composent ce cuir cette table ou autre a
été fabriqué beaucoup plus tard beaucoup
beaucoup plus tard pour ça que l'eau est
si précieuse c'est à la fois évidemment
le liquide de la vie mais c'est aussi
comment peut-on dire ça le témoin le
thermomètre le l'observatoire de ce
qu'était l'univers
il y a très très longtemps et tout ce
qu'il a dedans et bien pas tout mais une
grande partie de ce qu'il y a dedans a
été fabriqué
dans les trois premières minutes de vie
de l'univers et plus jamais après c'est
là le miracle
un miracle inwi
puisqu'on parle de miracle là où ça
commence à devenir fascinant c'est ce
qui s'est passé avant
ce premier instant qu'on appelle le Big
Bang c'est l'objet de nos recherches de
nos tests doctorat
Igor et moi dans ce début des années 90
on s'est dit on va tourner un peu la
page de temps X de l'émission qu'on a
fait dans lequel Jean-Claude d'ailleurs
était notre invité il est venu souvent
sur sur le plateau de temps X
sur TF1 et donc on a tourné la page on
s'est dit ben on va aller chercher ce
qui s'est passé avant le big bang et
pendant des années nous avons fait des
calculs chercher etc et nous sommes
arrivés à une conclusion que nous
considérons être une
découverte personnelle sur lequel les
scientifiques sont plus ou moins
d'accord certaines ne le sont pas du
tout d'autres le sont complètement
selon laquelle avant et vous allez
suivre mon raisonnement et puis on va en
rester là mais puisque la matière n'est
à cet instant qu'on appelle l'instant de
plan qui est l'instant du Big Bang
et puisque cet instant n'est pas
l'instant zéro l’instant de planque
c'est un instant très petit c'est 10
puissance - 43 secondes c'est très petit
mais c'est pas 0 bah il y a lieu de se
poser la question de savoir s'il y avait
quelque chose avant et bien oui il y a
quelque chose avant mais puisque la
matière la matière celle-là celle que je
touche la l'eau et la matière qui existe
tout autour de nous dans l'univers
puisqu'elle est née à ce moment-là ça
veut dire que avant le big bang n'existe
pas encore vous êtes d'accord avec ce
raisonnement
c'est logique la matière nerveau du Big
Bang donc elle n'existe pas avant et
bien si elle n'existe pas avant il y a
quelque chose d'immatériel qui précède
la matière et ce quelque chose
d'immatériel c'est le calcul qui nous
l'enseigne et bien
ça correspond un petit peu au plan de
l'univers ou si vous voulez au programme
de l'univers de la même manière que
cette très belle salle ici a été
précédée par des plans bon c'est ça elle
existe physiquement mais avant ça il y
avait des plans soit sur ordinateur soit
sur de magnifiques papier qui à plat
représentait
ces formes magnifiques ce volume
de la même manière que un être humain
est précis des lui aussi par des plans
un être vivant quel qu'il soit une
créature vivante c'est des plans qu'on
appelle le code génétique les plans
bien de la même manière ce que nous
pensons parce que c'est au fond les
mathématiques qui nous l'enseignent de
la même manière la phase physique de
l'univers est précédé par une phase
numérique nous vivons à l'air du
numérique et on peut comprendre que
avant
que la matière émerge et bien
il y avait ce que on appelle aujourd'hui
dans le monde numérique en cloud dans le
Cloud vous savez c'est toutes vos
données qui sont dans le nuage et bien
l'univers lui aussi était dans les
nuages avant dans les nuages mais sous
une forme qui était chiffrée sous une
forme qui était codée ce code qu'on
appelle génétique pour les êtres vivants
bien nous l'appelons
cosmologique pour l'univers et là aussi
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
ça veut dire que nous sommes pas là par
hasard ça veut dire que quelque chose
quelque chose sans qu'on puisse dire
quoi mais que quelque chose a dessiné
ces plans les a en quelque sorte
encadrés
pour que de manière aussi précise que ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
98% de la matière de l'univers puisse
émerger comme ça mais c'est pas par
hasard ça c'est fait selon des plans
rigoureux sinon en 180 secondes jamais
la totalité de ce que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui la masse matérielle de
l'univers à 98% n'aurait pu apparaître
c'est absolument extraordinaire parce
que voilà un discours c'est même pas un
discours c'est une constatation
scientifique objective avec des
hypothèses brillantes personnelles on ne
l'entend jamais
je regrette que la télévision qui
devrait être un instrument de culture ne
fasse pas appel à
Igor et Grichka parce que ça permettrait
au moins d'ouvrir les esprits mais tu ne
nous a toujours pas dit au-delà du mur
de Planck au-delà de l'explosion entre
guillemets du Big Bang comment tu
imagines cette intelligence ou ce hasard
ou se mathématicien qui sont à l'origine
de notre propre existence
on va exclure le hasard bien sûr puisque
elle a dit si on admet l'existence d'un
code cosmologique c'est-à-dire en fait
d'une d'une information qui précède
l'univers physique à ce moment-là on
doit écrire le hasard le hasard apparaît
de façon locale bien sûr que le hasard
existe dans nos vies ou en tout cas ce
que nous interprétons comme le hasard
parce que c'est vrai que
Poincaré lui-même a dit que c'était un
grand mathématicien qui a beaucoup
réfléchi sur cette question là il a dit
mais pour moi le hasard correspond à une
information incomplète
tout simplement parce que nous n'avons
pas toutes les données qui correspondent
à l'exploration d'un phénomène et bien
on va dire aussi le hasard et bien non
en effet plus l'information émerge de
notre connaissance plus le hasard recule
et en ce qui concerne le début de
l'univers on peut dire que le hasard n'y
a pas sa place parce que quand on
regarde le réglage de ce qu'on appelle
la constante universelle c'est-à-dire en
fait ce qui a permis justement la
synthèse d'un nucléose Saint-Esprit
mondiale les premiers atomes d'hydrogène
d'apparaître par contre j'ai mon
téléphone ça c'est pas le Alpha du
Centaure
du Centaure et bien à ce moment là
il y a 13 milliards à 820 millions
d'années le hasard n'existe pas il
n'existe pas et on le voit dans
l'observation
quand on regarde par exemple la première
image qui a été émise par l'univers qui
devient visible transparent jusqu'à un
appareil 380000 ans après le Big Bang on
voit
l'Univers primordial on le voit on
l'observe c'est ce qu'a vu de satellite
plante or cet univers primordial et
l'empreinte de ce que deviendra plus
tard l'univers que nous observons
aujourd'hui on y voit les plans d'une
certaine façon de l'univers qui 13
milliards 820 millions d'années après
sera observable on y voit quoi on y voit
l'emplacement de notre futur Galaxy on y
voit l'emplacement du groupe local on y
voit
les densités de matière on y voit les
densités de vide au niveau de tout ce
que donnera l'univers c'est le bébé
univers c'est le foetus si on peut dire
de l'univers oui puis on y voit surtout
un extraordinaire réglage dès cette
époque alors le réglage entre quoi et
quoi et bien entre les points chauds et
les points froids
les points chauds c'est la future
matière les points froids c'est le futur
vide entre les galaxies mais vous savez
quelle est la différence entre les
points chauds et le point froid et bien
il est à peine de 2 millionième de
degrés c'est tellement peu ça veut dire
que le réglage était inouï et pourtant
c'est de ce petit 2 millionnaire de
degrés que nous sommes issus donc ça
veut dire que le hasard n'existe pas en
tant que on ne le voit apparaître que de
façon locale mais jamais de façon
globale et
ce que nous pouvons en conclure c'est
tout simplement que l'univers repose sur
des lois
que comme la des Poincaré encore une
fois il a eu une phrase absolument
magnifique il a dit l'univers n'est
jamais hors la loi
il ne peut pas se dérober aux lois qui
le gouvernent il est soumis à ses lois
si je prends mon téléphone portable qui
vient de sonner je le lâche on sait que
la prédiction est certaine il va tomber
il va tomber parce qu'il obéit à la
puissante loi de la gravitation il peut
pas se dérober on peut jouer justement
la question s'aimer c'est loin elles
sont faites de quoi je vous donne juste
un exemple il faut que vous le gardiez
en tête un exemple puisqu'on parle de
ces lois ces lois précèdent l'univers
elles sont avant sont en quelque sorte
ces éléments du code dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure et bien prenons juste un
exemple
quelque chose que vous connaissez tous
les jours vous l'avez sous la main si on
peut dire c'est le nombre pi vous savez
pis c'est 3,14 15 92 35 35 je suis tombé
d'ailleurs sur une blague qui m'a
beaucoup fait rire vous savez que il y a
des soldes en ce moment et là je vois on
voit le nombre pi qui est à vendre et
3,14 au départ et puis bon 3 14 et
barrés c'est 3
on tombe comme ça grâce évidemment à la
facétie de certains dessinateurs dans ce
qui peut fasciner fasciné dans le nombre
pi 3 14
etc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
jusqu'à l'infini ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est de se dire que PI
et graines c'est décimal l'infini à
l'infini mais qu'il est exactement
l'infini c'est que il existe des
formules la une au 17e siècle avec
calculé le nombre pi de manière très
exacte pour l'époque puis on est revenu
grâce aux ordinateurs aujourd'hui il y a
des chiffrages encore plus exacts et on
connaît aujourd'hui des milliards de
décimales après la virgule et pourtant
c'est comme si on avait rien calculé ben
oui des milliards de décimales quand on
sait qu'il en existe une affinité ça
veut dire que on a rien calculé qu'on ne
calculera jamais vous savez qu'il existe
aujourd'hui au nom de particuliers
élémentaires 10 puissance 120 c'est pas
beaucoup particulièrement terre dans
l'univers et bien quand on aura été à la
10 puissance 120e décimale de Pi on aura
en quelque sorte
agrafer calculé toute grâce à ce nombre
pi toutes les décimales donc ça veut
dire jusqu'à 10 puissance 120 dans
toutes les particules mais au-delà ça va
calculer continuer à calculer et à
l'infini il fallait donc un programme
infini en quelque sorte pour engendrer
quelque chose qui est exact et réglé à
l'infini
et ça nous amène vers une question
incroyable qui était posée par un enfant
un enfant d'une dizaine d'années en 1936
Einstein on parlait tout à l'heure
d'Einstein qui le grand scientifique
emblématique qui lui s'est posé beaucoup
de questions sur sur Dieu justement et
au sortir de d'un de ses cours à
l'université de brinston en 1936
Einstein donc voire de débouler devant
lui un enfant qui arrive avec des grands
yeux et qui lui pose une question maître
est-ce que est-ce que vous croyez en
Dieu
Stein répond
voyons c'est une question très profonde
je peux pas y répondre comme ça
donne-moi ton adresse
et je t'écrirai ma réponse d'ici
quelques temps en effet 15 jours plus
tard l'enfant reçoit de la main
d'Einstein sur une belle enveloppe
l'écriture même du maître il reçoit une
réponse
qui dit ceci tous ceux qui sont
sérieusement impliqués dans la science
finiront par comprendre un jour
que les lois
se manifestent dans la science que ces
lois sont portées par un esprit
un esprit
immensément supérieur à celui de l'homme
c'était en 1936 donc il pensait Einstein
à l'existence
d'un esprit qui s'exprime dans les Lois
de l'Univers un esprit immensément
supérieur à celui de l'homme il n'a pas
dit que c'était Dieu mais il le sentait
il le pensait il le voyait devant lui
comme si c'était écrit un esprit se
manifeste dans les lois de l'univers
un esprit immensément supérieur à celui
de l'homme Einstein quittait le
découvreur vous savez de cet édifice
mathématico scientifiques
impressionnant qu'on appelle la
relativité générale
est-ce que vous voulez que je vous donne
la formule de la relativité générale
pour vous
je donne
le donne connaissez tous ceux = MC carré
évidemment ça c'est la formule de la
relativité restreinte maintenant la
formule de la relativité générale c'est
plus générale c'est plus poétique
quelque part vous allez voir ça s'écrit
comme ça
herminue plus un demi de G menu r
= Kappa diminue
plus un demi de Gemini R =
tenseur de courbure
R
donc vous avez deux fois R est revenu
plus un demi des Geminus r C'est le
tenseur de combien c'est à dire tout ce
qui touche à la géométrie de l'univers
et puis à droite
égal 2 minutes et c'est ce qu'on appelle
le tenseur impulsion énergie c'est à
dire c'est ce qui concentre la matière
et tout le génie d'Einstein
il y a un état de matière dans lequel on
vit mais aussi un état d'énergie dans
lequel on vit et tout ça c'est procédé
par un autre État qui est celui de
l'information information énergie
matière
bien entendu question nous n'hésitez pas
on me dit effectivement que ce serait
bien de vous donner la parole et donc je
vous la donne avec la permission d'Igor
et de Grichka immédiatement si vous avez
des questions à poser vous levez la main
on vous donne un micro
et en attendant que la première question
se manifeste je voudrais juste vous
citer la sourate
53 qui s'appelle l'étoile
ou Mahomet est dans le désert et où il
voit descendre ce qu'il appelle la lune
à l'intérieur de cette lune décrit un
être vivant qui l'appelle l'archange de
jebryl alors quand je Gabriel
et dans la sourate 53 l'étoile du Coran
114 sourates il est écrit que Mahomet
dit et je vis cela à moins de deux
portées d'Arc une portée d'Arc c'est 50
mètres donc il voit ça à moins de 100
mètres et même plus près
est-il écrit dans le Coran rapportant
les paroles du prophète et je sais ce
qu'il m'a dit pourquoi je vous cite cela
parce que je suis parvenu au bout de
près de 50 ans d'études de tous les
textes sacrés des textes scientifiques à
la certitude
qu'il y a eu un ou plusieurs contacts
entre des civilisations une ou des
civilisations extraterrestres qui sont
venus nous visiter il y a des siècles
des millénaires et nos ancêtres et que
l'origine des religions c'est ce contact
qui a été mal interprété et si vous
voulez avoir quelque chose de très
précis de très troublants de totalement
inexplicable regardez l'affaire de
Fatima Fatima c'est pas il y a 2000 ans
c'était en 1917 et c'était au Portugal
et il y a eu des
centaines de milliers de témoins sur
rendez-vous c'est ça le miracle de
Fatima ça a commencé le 13 mai
1717 puis le 13 juin le 13 juillet le 13
août ça n'a pas eu lieu parce que on
avait fait arrêter les deux petites
bergers et le petit berger parce que ça
mettait une pagaille absolument
incroyable au Portugal mais ils sont
venus en septembre et le 13 octobre 1917
la dame de lumière avait promis qu'elle
ferait un grand miracle et qu'est-ce que
c'était que cette dame de lumière que
seul les enfants voyaient et entendez
il y avait dans le ciel quelque chose
qui arrivait qui s'arrêtait à la
verticale de l'olivier
l'olivier était d'un seul coup saisi
comme par une main invisible et Tremblay
les petites bergers le petit berger se
mettaient à genoux les gens qui ne
voyaient rien et qui n'entendaient rien
mais qui regardait les enfants qui eux
voyaient entendaient se mettaient aussi
à genoux et on a jamais donné la moindre
explication rationnelle à ce qui s'est
passé donc il y a certainement puisque
notre monde n'a que 4 milliards et demi
d'années et que l'univers après 14
milliards d'années il y a certainement
une ou deux civilisations qui sont venus
nous visiter
ces civilisations c'est l'épisode du
paradis terrestre où il est interdit de
manger du fruit défendu et de l'arbre de
la connaissance
il y a certainement eu une modification
génétique du singe de l'époque et le
singe de 20 intelligent et il est là le
singe ici et puis dans la salle c'est à
dire qu'on est à la fois une bête ce qui
explique toutes les pulsions toutes les
violences que l'on voit autour de nous
et puis on est capable de se transcender
on est capable d'être un ange si j'ose
dire et on est finalement un produit
hybride un produit encore raté en
attendant qu'il y ait peut-être une
véritable civilisation qui soit à la
hauteur de l'immensité de l'univers et
de son âge alors qui veut poser la
première question
allez-y bonsoir et on m'entend donc ma
question portera pas sur les ovnis il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire sur le
sujet il me faudrait faire je pense une
soirée entière sur ce sujet donc OVNI et
religion c'est vrai que ça peut
interpeller ma question va être sur le
sujet principal de la soirée les
exoplanètes
ma question est est-ce qu'un jour vous
pensez qu'on pourra toucher ses planètes
autrement qu'avec les yeux c'est à dire
que pensez-vous des voyages
interstellaires et par rapport aux
connaissances scientifiques que l'on a
aujourd'hui sur le sujet les limites que
sont la vitesse de la lumière et les
distances énormes qui nous séparent de
ces exoplanètes comment envisager qu'un
jour on puisse se déplacer et atteindre
physiquement ces mondes qui
effectivement auront peut-être demain
une signature qui montreront que ces
montres portent la vie
mais comment y aller éventuellement un
jour physiquement avec quels moyens et
voilà
alors avant que
Igor et grichkan ne répondent je vais
faire ma propre réponse puisque en
collaboration avec Jean-Pierre Petit
ancien directeur de recherche du CNRS
nous avons publié il y a une quinzaine
de jours
contacte cosmique jusqu'au bout peut-on
penser trop loin et Jean-Pierre Petit a
repris l'équation d'Einstein que tu as
cité il y a un instant la transcendée et
a expliqué que finalement ce qui
existait autour de nous c'était un autre
univers un univers de masse
négative où la vitesse de la lumière et
les distances et la vitesse de la
lumière était motivée par 10 et les
distances étaient divisées par 100 ce
qui fait un facteur 1000 ce qui
expliquerait que une civilisation puisse
nous rendre visite puisque au lieu de
mettre 1000 ans par exemple pour nous
parvenir parce qu'elle est amis l'un des
lumières elle ne mettrait en passant par
l'univers négatif qu'une année alors je
simplifie énormément parce qu'évidemment
vous verrez toutes les explications
rationnellement scientifiques que nous
publié de la façon la plus claire claire
possible avec des témoignages d'ovnis
récents comme ces chasseurs F-15
d'un porte-avions nucléaire américain
qui pendant deux jours ont joué à
cache-cache avec un objet volant en
identifié en plein jour parfaitement
observée filmé visible avec des vidéos
qui ont été déclassifiées il y a peu de
temps et on ne sait toujours pas ce que
c'est avec des rapidités de déplacement
hallucinante puisque l'ovni parcourait
150 km en une fraction de seconde donc
c'est quelque chose de totalement
inimaginable nous sommes confrontés à
une intelligence venait d'ailleurs qui
est peut-être toujours en ce moment
parmi tout alors réponse à la question
Grichka et Igor je ne sais pas qui veut
répondre
alors c'est une question mais qui est
hallucinante nous sommes sur terre et
nous voyons ces étoiles par millions par
milliard au-dessus de nous on envoie
6000 à l'œil nu mais on sait qu'il en
existe des milliards déjà dans notre
seul galaxie et puis des milliards de
galaxies là évidemment c'est hallucinant
mais on peut pas rester là il faut y
aller vous savez ce qu'a dit le
fondateur de l'astronautique
constantinkowski un de nos
compatriotes puisque nigorellement nous
sommes d'origine russe et bien il disait
l'humanité est née sur terre mais quand
même tout de même on peut pas passer
toute sa vie dans son berceau va falloir
changer mais pour aller là-bas
et bien même si on prend les engins les
plus rapides dont nous pouvons rêver sur
terre admettons qu'on fasse un million
de kilomètres à l'heure allez je dis
même on va multiplier par 10 10 millions
de km/h c'est énorme est-ce que vous
savez combien de temps cette vitesse là
il nous faudrait pour aller sur la
fameuse planète gravitant autour de
notre plus proche voisin Alpha du
Centaure et bien il nous faudrait 70
000 ans voilà 70 000 ans et la même
chose pour revenir donc
il n'y a pas de solution aucune solution
nous sommes prisonniers de la terre si
on s'en remet au système classique un
certain auteurs se sont dit bah vous
pourrez peut-être essayer d'augmenter la
vitesse avec des moyens qui seraient par
exemple ultra photonique et bien on
pourrait peut-être peut-être avec des
moyens qu'on appelle
ultra relativiste c'est ce que l'on
appelle la physique ultra relativiste et
bien se déplacer à des vitesses proches
de la vitesse de la lumière oui mais
voilà problème c'est que quand on
augmente la vitesse mais la masse de la
fusée dans laquelle on se déplacerait et
augmente à proportion et quand on arrive
à des seuils très proches de la vitesse
de la lumière à supposer qu'on y arrive
mais pour ça il faudrait une énergie
colossale et bien
il n'y aurait pas assez de ressources
d'énergie pour propulser une
navire un vaisseau qui aurait une fusée
qui aurait une inertie mais gigantesque
sa masse serait gigantesque la masse ça
c'est la théorie de la relativité
augmente à mesure que la vitesse
augmente c'est comme ça c'est une
barrière donc la barrière ultime c'est
celle des photons on ne peut pas aller
plus vite que la vitesse de la lumière
alors est-ce que pour autant on est
condamné à rester sur terre et bien
soyons optimistes comme vous savez
également en l'air on le disait
d'ailleurs dans nos émissions rayons X
qui passaient sur France 2 pendant à peu
près une petite dizaine d'années dans
les années 2000-2010
et bien rien n'est impossible on disait
dans l'univers rien n'est impossible et
bien nous pensons que le voyage
interstellaire c'est-à-dire donc le
déplacement hors de notre orbite système
solaire est possible mais comment est-ce
que c'est possible alors représenter
juste comme ça mentalement ce qu'est
l'univers et l'univers c'est une sphère
à trois dimensions attention c'est pas
comme la boule de glace ça a une
dimension de plus vous pouvez pas vous
la représenter mais mettons ça à deux
dimensions mettons que l'univers c'est
une boule de glace
ou une boule de tennis ou un ballon de
foot comme vous voulez qui se déplace en
grandissant à chaque instant parce que
l'univers grandit à chaque instant il
grandit
en créant en quelque sorte un sillage
derrière lui ce sillage c'est quoi mais
c'est un cône c'est un cône puisque une
sphère qui grandit supposons que le
ballon par exemple de foot soit gonflé
il va créer autour de lui un sillage qui
est en forme comme un cône alors vous
imaginez vous êtes avec un cornet de
glace et puis vous avez la boule de
glace c'est un petit peu comme ça par
exemple et bien c'est ça la
représentation géométrique qui a été
d'ailleurs déterminée par le professeur
de mathématiques d'Einstein qui
s'appelait Herman mingkovski qui a
publié son premier article l'âge de 16
ans qui était un génie de mathématiques
et qui a été celui qui a permis Einstein
de construire la relativité restreinte
puis par la suite qui était généralisé
un volatilité générale mais donc nous
avons une représentation géométrique un
cône que figurez-vous les physiciens
relativistes appellent le cône de
lumière voilà ce qu'est l'univers
l'univers il est représenté par ce qu'on
appelle un conte de lumière puisqu'il
part de zéro c'est-à-dire donc le moment
du Big Bang puis qui ne cesse de grandir
toute cette
dynamique de l'univers est représentée
par un cône nous sommes à l'intérieur du
cône et les rayons lumineux vous dire
donc les photons et ben c'est
l'enveloppe du cône et nous nous sommes
très proches de la verticale du cône
c'est de l'axe vertical puisque on n'a
pas de vitesse là par exemple nous
sommes immobile mais si nous allons très
très vite de plus en plus vite et bien
la ligne d'univers que nous allons
suivre à basculer de plus en plus vers
l'enveloppe vers les limites du cône
et bien mes amis mon pari et que on sera
un jour capable de franchir l'enveloppe
du cône de lumière de l'espace-temps
c'est ça la réponse à la question que
vous posez car à l'extérieur c'est un
paysage complètement nouveau de la
réalité qui s'ouvre un paysage
qui était décrit par l'extraordinaire et
fertile imagination des auteurs de
science-fiction sous la forme de
hyperespace vous savez dans la guerre
des étoiles dans Star Trek etc on plonge
dans un tunnel sous l'univers qu'on
appelle l'hyperespace
cette hyper espace d'un point de vue
physico-mathématique du point de vue de
la physique mathématique à un sens c'est
l'extérieur du cône de lumière de
l'espace-temps
là le temps n'existe plus ou en tout cas
plus sous la forme traditionnelle du
temps mesurée par nos montres le temps
réel non il est représenté par un temps
qu'on appelle le temps imaginaire
attention le temps imaginaire n'est pas
un temps de l'imagination c'est un temps
qui est mesuré par des nombreux
imaginaires qu'est-ce que les nombres
imaginaires ce sont des nombres dans le
carré et toujours négatif alors que les
nombres réels leur carré est toujours
positif de X2 ça fait 4 - 2 au carré ça
fait 4 mais il existe des nombres qui
s'appelle I
dont le carré est égal à - 1 2 i² ça
fait -4 et bien quand vous prenez des
nombres imaginaires pour mesurer le
temps vous tombez sur un nouveau type de
temps qu'on appelle le temps imaginaire
et là ça veut dire qu'il n'existe plus
ça veut dire que le temps ne s'écoule
plus là-bas et d'ailleurs avec une
extraordinaire impulsion intuition
Einstein a appelé cette région l'Ayur
imaginez que nous puissions nous
déplacer vers l’ailleurs la touche car
nous pouvons sortir d'une région du cône
de lumière allez dans le futur du conte
de lumière ou au contraire dans le passé
du compte de lumière et nous pouvons
aller n'importe où et nous pouvons
rejoindre des régions extrêmement
lointaines
conditions évidemment d'avoir un GPS de
libérer espace mais ça on l'aura c'est
juste un petit détail d'ailleurs vous le
savez le GPS n'existe aujourd'hui sur
mon téléphone portable que grâce au
calcul de la relativité
donc c'est la théorie de la relativité
qui est permis la naissance du GPS donc
on va généraliser tout ça et on aura un
GPS qui sera évidemment
interstellaire alors à partir de là
on est passé de l'autre côté du comte de
lumière donc dans une région qu'on
appelle l'hyperespace que on appelle
l'ayeur selon le discours de la
relativité générale
et on est capable de se déplacer à des
vitesses qui sont en affranchi le mur de
la lumière en quelque sorte
mais on est capable de le franchir grâce
à des
contraintes physiques que je pourrais
détailler si ça vous intéresse je
propose d'ailleurs que ceux qui sont
intéressés et bien me pose cette
question et on prendra un certain nombre
de je sais pas par exemple 5 ou 6 heures
pour pour entrer dans le détail et que
je vous réponde vraiment mais donc les
volontaires
bon je refais un apparentès mais en tout
cas vous savez juste pour que vous ayez
des chiffres en tête vous qui êtes des
mathématiciens vous savez que le temps
c'est en relativité c'était 0 égal t
facteurs de racine carrée de 1 - 2 sur
C2 V c'est la vitesse d'un mobile c'est
la vitesse de la lumière et bien lorsque
V est supérieur à c bien
√a - B2 sur C2 devient négative donc
vous avez été bascule vers T0 fois le un
nombre imaginaire donc c'est comme ça
qu'on atteint le temps imaginaire vous
voyez comme c'est tout simple oui
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il existe sur la
terre des objets qui s'affranchissent en
effet du ce qu'on appelle le cours qui
traverse l'enveloppe du cône de lumière
langage qui a parlé ce sont des
expériences dont vous connaissez
évidemment le nom sous une forme grand
public on appelle ça l'effet tunnel
qu'est-ce que c'est que les faitunelles
et bien c'est une particule une
particule qui est dans un point A
et qu'on va retrouver instantanément un
point B
et la franchi la distance qui sépare
physiquement ces deux points
hors du temps hors du temps ordinaire la
franchit dans ce qu'on appelle le temps
imaginaire pourquoi parce que il s'est
écoulé zéro seconde entre le moment où
la particule disparaît du point A et où
elle réapparaît sur le point B ça c'est
son expérience renseignez-vous regardez
et fait une aile ça permet en effet tout
simplement de transporter de la matière
des particules d'un point à un autre
hors du temps ordinaire et bien c'est ce
qui va se passer qu'est-ce qui a pris le
pari tout à l'heure moi je je joins je
rejoins ce pari et je ressens que dans
les peut-être pas dans les années qui
viennent malheureusement la fin en tout
cas dans les dans les peut-être dans les
siècles qui à venir ont voyagera vers
des étoiles lointaines en
s'affranchissant du cône lumière en
quittant notre espace notre espace-temps
ordinaire et en allant donc très très
longtemps extraordinaire
Igor et Grichka on me demande d'arrêter
à 10h30 il 24
donc je vais si vous le permettez
redonner la parole à la salle et vous
demandez des réponses courtes c'est à
dire des réponses de moins de 45 minutes
si c'est possible oui c'est vrai pour
d'ailleurs la prochaine question
question courte réponse courte alors
qu'est-ce qu'on court je voulais vous
poser trois questions mais en vérité je
vais en vous en poser je vais essayer
d'en poser qu'une
alors tout d'abord enfin la première
question c'est
quand on parliez vous monsieur bourré de
l'ifologie en général de la théorie des
anciens astronautes j'aimerais bien
avoir la vie de des Gori Grichka parce
que c'est une bon c'était une théorie
qui est très discutée donc voilà les les
preuves les livres de John images ou de
Eric van Daniken sont soit un peu
nébuleux donc quand j'aimerais avoir la
parole de scientifiques sur ce genre de
théorie puisque on parle de vie ailleurs
mais
vous vous parlez donc de de contact avec
des êtres humains la deuxième question
c'est est-ce que Hugo et Grichka ont
déjà lu des livres de science-fiction de
Greg egane ou de Stephen Baxter ou de
Peter watts pour savoir si si ils ont
déjà pris connaissance de ces de ces
auteurs et de leurs moyens justement de
s'affranchir de la vitesse de la lumière
et j'avais une troisième question un peu
plus scientifique qui s'éloigne un peu
du sujet est-ce que vous avez travaillé
personnellement sur des réponses sur la
conciliation entre entre la la
relativité générale et la mécanique
quantique sur la gravité quantique à
boucle ou sur la théorie des cordes
avez-vous des des pistes sérieuses
puisque ça aussi ça pourrait nous aider
justement à s'affranchir de de la
vitesse de la lumière et donc à imaginer
une colonisation de d'autres planètes
alors en ce qui concerne votre dernière
question c'est très exactement l'un des
thèmes de du dernier livre nous venons
de publier avec Jean-Pierre Petit il y a
une quinzaine de jours donc je vous y
renvoie parce que on ne peut pas
développer ça en deux minutes mais c'est
tout à fait clairement exposé en ce qui
concerne l'histoire des religions je
j'invite chacun d'entre vous quel que
soit son sa croyance qui soit juive
chrétien protestant musulman hindou ou
un croyant s'il a une bible chez lui à
lire au moins le début de la Genèse
c'est à dire le début de l'Ancien
Testament et vous verrez qu'il suffit de
lire je n'invente rien je
n'interprétiens quand il quand il est
écrit que les fils de Dieu trouvèrent
les fils de la guerre de la terre à leur
goût
je pense que les mots ont une
signification et qu'ils eurent commerce
à elle et qui leur firent des enfants
voilà donc moi ça m'a ouvert l'esprit et
ça m'a permis de comprendre que comme
dans le Coran avec la sourate 53 mais la
sourate 54 aussi la lune puisque Mahomet
décrit la lune qui se coupe en deux avec
une moitié de la lune qui descend sur
Terre l'image est très parlante ça me
permet de comprendre qu'il y a eu sans
doute des visites de d'extraterrestres
qui ont continué longtemps qui
continuent évidemment aujourd'hui
puisqu'il y a des centrales nucléaires
qui sont survolés par des objets volants
d'une identifiés
et que les autorités sont parfaitement
au courant puisque Robert Gallet le
ministre de la Défense me l'avait
confirmé dans son propre bureau de
ministre de la Défense en
1972 ou 73 je me suis un peu exactement
et qu'il avait sur son bureau je me
souviens peut-être 250 rapports que je
voyais à l'envers j'aurais bien aimé en
piqué un ou deux je voyais les gros
cachets rouges très secret défense
secret confidentiel
alors voilà pour la réponse à vos
questions encore une question peut-être
avant qu'on ne conclu allez-y alors qui
a le micro
bonjour Corinne boisbuche je suis
biographe écrivain public et je peux
vous dire que depuis un moment vous
parlez chinois pour moi parce que je
suis beaucoup plus littéraire que
j'ai juste une petite question au sujet
du chevalier noir est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui existe vraiment ou qui
a existé ou bien c'est simplement une
histoire inventée par des farfelus alors
Grichka
je pensais que Jean-Claude allait
le chevalier noir
oui enfin
je suppose que vous faites allusion une
créature enfin une création de l'esprit
parce que personnellement enfin en tout
cas dans dans le courant de
l'observation de ce qui a pu exister je
n'ai pas l'exemple de ce qui pourrait
être moi non plus le chevalier noir donc
à moins qu'il gore peut-être non non
malheureusement je sais pas on va être
très déceptif on va vous décevoir mais
je non je ne connais pas il s'agissait
d'un satellite qui aurait été pris en
photo un satellite tout à fait
enfin non naturel enfin fabriqué par
quelque chose ou quelqu'un
et il a été il y a plusieurs
gouvernements qui ont tenté de
l'approcher et
apparemment c'était impossible de
l'approcher puisque les
multiples mystères auxquels nous sommes
confrontés et la réponse d'Igor de le
cas et de moi-même c'est on ne sait pas
on ne peut pas tout savoir donc là on ne
sait pas autre question
il est vraiment la dernière
ce sera d'ailleurs la dernière ou
l'avant-dernière à moins que quelqu'un
hurle en disant non j'en avais une à
poser allez-y parce qu'après il y a la
signature vous pouvez rencontrer
Igor et crischka et Jean-Claude Bourret
bonsoir enchanté j'aurais juste un
éclaircissement sur les monuments de
parler mais est-ce que ça existe
vraiment ou c'est complètement farfelu
le fait
brièvement brièvement non je pense que
la théorie des multiniveurs est une
théorie qui est depuis Everett c'était
donc depuis les années 60 a pris une
certaine vogue en sciences nous pensons
personnellement que il est déjà très
difficile de comprendre l'univers tel
qu'il est donc le l'univers c'est 1 unit
vers et qu'il est probablement peu
comment dire
peu réfutable
de parler de multivers quand j'ai dit
purifutable vous savez que il existe des
des tests en sciences qui font qu'une
réalité scientifique ou pas qu'une
observation un phénomène est
scientifique ou pas donc quand on parle
de test il y en a un qui est très
important qui était mis en évidence par
Karl poppers qui le test réfutabilité
c'est qu'on peut réfuter une théorie ou
pas en fait la théorie des univers
parallèles n'est pas réputable
c'est-à-dire que elle n'est même pas
fausse comme dirait Nice bord ou
d'autres elle n'est pas réfutable on
peut pas la contester ce qui veut dire
que on ne peut ni la prouver ni la
contester par conséquent elle n'est pas
scientifique et puisqu'elle n'est pas
scientifique il vaut mieux se contenter
de une représentation de notre réalité
sous la forme d'un univers unique
merci infiniment Grichka merci
Igor merci à vous tous pour votre
attention et pour vos questions nous
sommes obligés de rendre l'antenne à
Cognac g malheureusement parce que nous
avons des
impératifs de décrochage on peut les
applaudir bien fort merci à tous merci
et
Igor et Grichka vont dédicacer leur
livre et je crois qu'il vient dans
quelques-uns des miens et vous pourrez
continuer à leur poser éventuellement
des questions merci bonne soirée et
regardez les étoiles
[Applaudissements]